SO WE'RE GOING TO BE
.
GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME THAT
SUBCOMMITTEE FORESTED
ADMINISTRATION TODAY WE'LL HEAR
FROM GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS
AGENCY ALSO FUNDING RESEARCH
THIS CAL. THE PART OF TECHNOLOGY
DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN RESOURCES
RIGHT NOW WE DO HAVE A QUORUM
CELS FOR OFFICES SUBCOMMITTEE.
WRESTLING GO OUT OF ORDER AND
START WITH ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN A
DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN RESOURCES
STATEWIDE HUMAN SOURCES OF
WORKLOAD.
NO FULLER HERE.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS RICHARD CALLAHAN
DIRECTOR OF COLLEGE ARE.
SOME THIS REQUEST BEFORE YOU
TODAY HAS TO DO.
LARGELY IN THE ONGOING
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE GOVERNOR
CIVIL SERVICE INITIATIVE
IMPROVEMENT INITIATIVE. AND I
KNOW SECRETARY PATCHES HERE AND
SHE'S GOING TO TALK MORE ABOUT.
THAT INITIATIVE ON AND WHERE WE
ARE IN OUR COMPLIMENTS.
SO I WON'T GO TO FUND A DETAIL
BUT.
THIS PROPOSAL.
.
THE FIRST PORTION OF IT IS SIX
POSITIONS AND REIMBURSEMENT
AUTHORITY IN OF ABOUT SEVEN
HUNDRED.
TWO THOUSAND A YEAR TO CONTINUE
OUR EXPANSION OF THE STATE'S
TRAINING CENTER.
REBUILDING THE STATE'S TRAINING
CENTER.
THAT WAS SHUT DOWN IN THE MIDST
OF THE S. ECONOMIC DOWNTURN.
THAT HAS BEEN A PRIORITY FOR US
AND.
THE TRAINING THAT WE'RE FOCUSED
ON IS RIGHT AT THE HEART OF OUR
CIVIL SERVICE IMPROVEMENT
PROJECT WHICH IS.
OUR LEADERSHIP TRAINING
STARTING WITH THAT THE
MANAGEMENT DEVELOPMENT TRAINING
THAT THE LEGISLATURE OF PUT INTO
STATUTE FOR US AS WELL AS
EXECUTIVE LEVEL TRAINING WORKING
ON DEVELOPING THAT NOW. I KNOW
WE'RE GONNA CYCLE BACK TO THE AB
OUR SUPERVISORS TRAINING WE FEEL
IT'S IMPORTANT THESE. LEADERSHIP
TRAINING MODULES BE.
THAT THERE BE A LINK BETWEEN
EACH OTHER SO THAT THEY BUILD
UPON EACH OTHER AND FOLLOW
PEOPLE THROUGH THEIR CAREER
PROGRESSION. BUT ALSO TIED BACK
TO OUR.
.
OUR OUR NEW LEARNING MODELS AND
OUR COMPETENCY MODEL WE DEVELOP
FOR FUTURE STATE LEADERS.
SO THIS EFFORT IS ALL AND I ALSO
OUR EFFORTS ARE FOCUSED ON
ARLENE TRAINING ARLENE ACADEMY
SO.
PERFORMANCE IMPROVEMENTS
EFFICIENCIES AND LEADERSHIP
TRAINING DEVELOPED DELIVERED BY
STATE EMPLOYEES TO STATE
EMPLOYEES.
AT THE SECOND PORTION HAS TO DO
WITH THE LEARNING MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM. WHICH IS A A CASE
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM TO ATTRACT
THAT EMPLOYEE TRAINING RECORDS.
YEAH THE SYSTEMS ARE.
BECOMING ONLINE RIGHT NOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY I
BELIEVE THERE'S TWO OF THEM.
AND.
BEYOND THAT.
KELLY TAUNTON'S USE THAT.
ADMINISTER THE STATE TRAINING
CENTER FOR REGISTRATIONS AND
ENROLLMENTS AND THINGS OF THAT
NATURE
AND. THERE'S A ONE POSITION AND
OUR.
THERE OF RESOURCES EXCUSE ME TO
ENHANCE AND EXPAND OUR.
PLAYING IS A PROGRAM WE. HAVE A
DEPARTMENT HEAD OF RD GONE
THROUGH IT OR ARE CURRENTLY
GOING THROUGH IT. AND MORE LINED
UP TO GO THROUGH NEXT YEAR.
AND.
.
THE LAST TWO PIECES ARE A
POSITION ON OUR SELECTION
DIVISION TO PROVIDE COMPLICATED
SERVICES TO DEPARTMENTS. AND THE
EFFICIENT DEVELOPMENT DELIVERY
OF EXAMINATIONS FOR CIVIL
SERVICE POSITIONS.
AND SOME CONSULTANT DOLLARS TO
HELP US WITH THE MULTI MEDIA
MATERIALS ANOTHER.
.
THINGS TO ENHANCE ARE
RECRUITMENT RETENTION EFFORTS
FOR STATE EMPLOYEES
WITHOUT HAVE TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS
THANK YOU FINANCE.
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL.
LL.
KING SO OF A QUORUM CERVANTES
LEADING OPEN.
WE GIVE FORMAL GOING VOTE ON IT.
.
NEXT WOULD GO BACK TO ISSUE
NUMBER ONE.
NOT SORRY.
ISSUE ISSUE NUMBER ONE.
CIVIL SERVICE FOR THE BILLING
WHICH.
WELL UPS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
REVENUE MILITARY THINK NOT LIKE
SAYING THAT.
I LOVE HEARING IT SOMETIME.
ESPECIALLY WHEN I'M WATCHING THE
MADAM SECRETARY.
THANK YOU FOR TAKING US OUT OF
ORDER.
THERE ARE A LOT OF YOUR
CITIZENS OUT THERE TRYING TO GET
INTO THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE RIGHT
NOW.
AND I WANT TO JUST TAKE A FEW
MINUTES IF I MAY MISTER CHAIRMAN
TO AND. GIVE YOU A UPDATE ON
CIVIL SERVICE IMPROVEMENT AS
WELL AS PUT IT INTO CONTEXT
WHERE WE ARE SO THE TAPE TRADE
TRAILER BILL THAT MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER REX WILL GO INTO DETAIL
ON. WILL I THINK HAVE A LITTLE
BIT MORE MEANING IF I MAY.
AND THE GOAL OF CIVIL SERVICE
IMPROVEMENT INITIATIVE IS TO
PRODUCE A MODERN HUMAN RESOURCE
SYSTEM THAT ALLOWS STATE
DEPARTMENTS TO FIND AND QUICKLY
HIRE. THE BEST CANDIDATES
THROUGH A FAIR AND MERIT BASED
PROCESS THE DEPARTMENTS WILL BE
ABLE TO SYSTEMATICALLY DETERMINE
THEIR WORKFORCE NEEDS AND WILL
BE EQUIPPED TO TRAIN AND DEVELOP
THEIR EMPLOYEES TO MAXIMIZE.
THEIR INDIVIDUAL POTENTIAL TO
BETTER SERVE THEIR DEPARTMENTS
MISSION.
AND IMPROVE CIVIL SERVICE SYSTEM
WILL PRODUCE A CAPABLE AND
ENGAGED STATE WORKFORCE THAT IS
ABLE TO ADAPT TO NEW CHALLENGES
AND SERVING THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND WILL REFLECT THE
DIVERSITY OF THE POPULATION IT
SERVES.
THIS IMPROVE CIVIL SERVICE
SYSTEM WILL MAKE CALIFORNIA AND
EMPLOYER OF CHOICE NOT ONLY FOR
PEOPLE WHO WANT A CAREER IN
PUBLIC SERVICE BUT ALSO FOR
THOSE WHO WANT TO MAKE A PUBLIC
SERVICE. A CHAPTER IN A BROADER
CAREER ESSENTIAL TO CREATING
THIS ENVIRONMENT IS ESTABLISHING
A LEADERSHIP CULTURE COMMITTED
TO DEVELOPING AN INSPIRING
EMPLOYEES. TO ACHIEVE GREAT
RESULTS.
MANAGERS ARE SUPPOSED IN THIS
EFFORT WITH YOU ARE SUPPORTED
USE ME IN THIS EFFORT WITH
MODERN ONLINE TOOLS AND PROGRAMS
RECRUIT TRACK AND DEVELOP
EMPLOYEES. THROUGHOUT THEIR
CAREERS IN STATE SERVICE
POTENTIAL EMPLOYEES ARE ABLE TO
USE MODERN TOOLS TO SUBMIT
APPLICATIONS TO ALL POSITIONS
FOR WHICH THEY'RE QUALIFIED.
APPLICANTS SEEKING STATE JOBS
ARE BETTER ABLE TO EASILY SS
WHAT CAREER EXIST IN THE STATE
GOVERNMENT WHAT POSITIONS MATCH
THEIR SKILLS AND INTERESTS AND
WHAT AVAILABLE OPENINGS FIT THAT
PROFILE.
THESE CHANGES ARE HELPING
DEPARTMENTS BE MORE EFFICIENT
AND RESPONSIVE IN THE HIRING
PROCESS
ONCE HIRED EMPLOYEES WILL BE PRO
PROPERLY ON BOARDED. AND TAUGHT
CRITICAL INFORMATION ABOUT THE
DEPARTMENTS AND JOB DUTIES SO
THAT THEY ARE SET UP FOR SUCCESS
AND CAN IMMEDIATELY START
CONTRIBUTING.
EMPLOYEES HAVE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES LEARN NEW SKILLS
AND EARNING RECOGNITION FOR
DOING GOOD WORK.
EXCUSE ME AS OPPORTUNITIES AND
NEW TECHNOLOGIES EMERGE
EMPLOYEES WILL HAVE CLEAR PATHS
FOR UPWARD MOBILITY AND CAN YOU
CONTINUE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT.
ENSURING THE EMPLOYEES BRING
VALUE TO THEIR WORK AND THAT
THEIR WORK ADDS VALUE TO THEIR
LIVES OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
EMPLOYEES ENGAGEMENT. AND
ATTRACT MOTIVATED CANDIDATES
THE TEST OF THE SYSTEM SUCCESS
WILL BE IN ITS ABILITY TO GET
THE RIGHT PEOPLE IN THE RIGHT
JOB. AT THE RIGHT TIME ENSURING
THEY HAVE THE TOOLS AND WORK
PROCESSES TO COMPLETE HIGH
QUALITY WORK.
TO MANAGE THE CSI INITIATIVE OF
THIS CAREER CIVIL SERVICE IN
IMPROVEMENT INITIATIVE GOV OPS
CREATED A GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE
STARTING WITH AN EXECUTIVE
COUNCIL.
THAT WORKED WITH STATE EXPERTS
ON IDENTIFYING THE MOST NEEDED
IMPROVEMENTS
ACSI OPERATIONS COMMITTEE
REPORTING TO THE EXECUTIVE
COUNCIL RECRUITED AND FORMED
WORK GROUPS OF STATE EMPLOYEES.
WHO RESEARCH THE IMPROVEMENTS
NEEDED AND DEVELOP
RECOMMENDATIONS
NEARLY TWO HUNDRED STATE
EMPLOYEES AND INNER?
EMPLOYEES REPRESENTATIVES HAVE
WORKED ON FORTY DIFFERENT WORK
GROUPS AT DIFFERENT TIMES THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS REVIEWED AND
DISCUSSED WITH OPERATIONS
COMMITTEE ARE PRESENTED TO THE
EXECUTIVE COUNCIL. FOR APPROVAL
AND IMPLEMENTATION SO ONE MIGHT
ASK WHAT IS WHAT HAS CSI
ACTUALLY ACHIEVED WE'VE DONE
CLASS CONSOLIDATION WHICH IS
CRITICAL TO OUR EFFORTS CLASS
CONSOLIDATION IS THE FIRST AND
FOREMOST FUNDAMENTAL STEP. IN
MODERNIZING THE STATE CIVIL
SERVICE SYSTEM.
CS I STARTED OFF IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN WITH THE STATE
PERSONNEL BOARD CLASS
CONSOLIDATION ANALYSIS OF NEARLY
FOUR THOUSAND JOB
CLASSIFICATIONS.
ASSESSING HOW THE STATE COULD
ELIMINATE SOME CLASSES AND
CONSOLIDATE OTHERS INTO BROADER
STATEWIDE CLASSES. ELIMINATING
DEPARTMENT SPECIFIC
CLASSIFICATIONS MAKES IT EASIER
FOR MANAGERS TO CREATE LARGE
POOLS OF QUALIFIED CANDIDATES
AND ALLOWS EMPLOYEES TO BROADEN
THEIR SEARCH WHEN LOOKING FOR A
PROMOTION. IT ALSO AVOIDS
ENORMOUS WORKLOAD AND EXPENSE OF
DEVELOPING OFFERING AND SCORING
DEPARTMENT SPECIFIC EXAMINATIONS
FOR CLASSIFICATIONS THAT DIFFER
ONLY IN TITLE.
BY CONSOLIDATING CLASSES EACH
DEPARTMENT NO LONGER HAS TO
SPEND HOURS DEVELOPING
INVALIDATING EXAMINATIONS.
BROADENING CLASSES REDUCES THE
OVERALL NUMBER OF EXAMINATIONS
NEEDED AND FOR EMPLOYEES
CLARIFIES POTENTIAL CAREER PATHS
THE HIRING PROCESS IS MORE
NIMBLE AS EMPLOYEES ARE ABLE TO
APPLY FOR CONTINUOUS
EXAMINATIONS FOR STATE WIDE
CLASSES.
SURE TO RECRUITMENT AND HIRING
TIMES ALLOWS THE STATE TO HIRE
CANDIDATES IN A MORE TIMELY
MANNER AS MANAGERS NO LONGER
HAVE TO BUILD IN ADDITIONAL
TIME.
FOR EXAMINATION PROCESS.
THESE IMPROVEMENTS ALLOW THE
STATE TO FOCUS ON MUCH NEEDED
RECRUITING HIRING AND ON
BOARDING EFFORTS.
CLASS CONSOLIDATION AND THE
BENEFITS IT GENERATES PROVIDES A
CRITICAL FOUNDATION FOR IMPROVE
CIVIL SERVICE SYSTEM.
SINCE JAN SINCE JUNE ONE TWENTY
FOURTEEN KELLY DURING THE STATE
PERSONNEL BOARD HAVE ABOLISHED
ONE THOUSAND TWENTY SIX CLASSES.
THE CIVIL SERVICE SYSTEM NOW HAS
FEWER THAN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED CLASSES.
CLASSIFICATIONS.
WE'VE ABOLISHED CLASSES VACANT
FOR TWO YEARS WE'VE INCREASED
MULTI DEPARTMENTAL EXAMINATIONS
WE'VE ELIMINATED OUTDATED
EXAMINATION RULES WE HAVE
SIMPLIFIED. THE LIMITED
EXAMINATION AN APPOINTMENT
PROGRAM LEAP AS IT IS KNOWN AS
AN ALTERNATIVE.
TORRENT. DIRECT EXAMINATION AN
APPOINTMENT PROCESS FOR THE
RECRUITMENT AND HIRING OF
INDIVIDUALS WOULD JUST DO IT
DISABILITIES INTO STATE SERVICE
UNDER CSI THE STATE HAS
ELIMINATED THE PROBATIONARY
PERIOD. FOR LEAP CANDIDATES
LEAVING JOB EVALUATION PERIOD
ONLY.
I IN THE AREA OF RECRUITING WE
CHANGE CREW EXECUTIVE ASSIGNMENT
RULES WHICH IS CRITICAL FOR THE
HIRING OF OUTSIDE TALENT INTO
THE STATE WE'VE IMPROVED
STATEWIDE RECRUITMENT. WE'VE
EXPANDED RECRUITMENT FOR
VETERANS WE'VE CREATED A PRISON
TO EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM WE'VE
LAUNCHED A RECRUITING PILOT WITH
LINKED IN. IN THE AREA OF
TRAINING IT WE'VE EXPANDED OUR
LEADERSHIP TRAINING FOR WHICH WE
ARE VERY PROUD YOU ALL.
WERE EXTREMELY HELPFUL WITH US
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN WHERE WE
WERE ABLE TO OVERHAUL AND DEEPEN
THE LEADERSHIP AND MANAGEMENT
TRAINING REQUIRED.
TO CHANGE IT WHICH READS IT
REQUIRES CHANGING STATUTE AND
NEW POLICY GUIDELINES ALL
SUPERVISORS MANAGERS AND CA'S
ARE NOW STATUTORILY REQUIRED TO
COMPLETELY TO SHIP AND
DEVELOPMENT TRAINING. EVERY TWO
YEARS AS PRESCRIBED BY KELLY
CHART.
CURRICULUM FOR THE NEW TRAINING
IS BUILT ON A NEW STATEWIDE
LEADERSHIP PHILOSOPHY VALUES IN
COMBAT SING MODEL WAS LEARNING
OBJECTIVES ASSOCIATED WITH EACH
LEVEL OF LEADERSHIP. THIS
PROVIDES DEPARTMENTS WITH
GUIDANCE ON HOW TO PROGRESSIVELY
DEVELOP LEADERS FROM SUPERVISORS
TO EXECUTIVE LEVEL POSITIONS.
S. B. B. BEGAN AUDITING BASIC
SUPERVISOR TRAINING AUGUST
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND ONE CORPORATE
THE CHANGES IN LAW WITH FUTURE
AUDITS.
WE'VE DEVELOPED APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS WE'VE STREAMLINED
PROCESSES AND ORGANIZATIONAL
DEVELOPMENT BY CREATING LEAN
TRAINING WE'VE LAUNCHED THE
FIRST STATEWIDE EMPLOYEE.
ENGAGEMENT SURVEY MAJORITY OF
OUR EMPLOYEES I'M HAPPY TO SAY
BELIEVE WHAT THEY DO IS
IMPORTANT TO THE LIVES OF
CALIFORNIANS FROM OUR SURVEY.
HOWEVER EMPLOYEES FEEL WE DO NOT
RISKS THEY DO NOT RECEIVE ENOUGH
RECOGNITION OF THE GOOD WORK
THAT THEY DO. SO GOV ABSENT
CALYX AE WORKING TOGETHER ON
EMPLOYEE ENGAGEMENT AND IN FACT
IN TWO WEEKS GOV OPS IS HOSTING
A SERIES OF FIVE EVENTS UP AND
DOWN THE STATE TIM. MARKET
PUBLIC SERVICE RECOGNITION WEEK
THAT'S MAY SEVENTH THROUGH MAY
ELEVENTH IF YOU'RE INTERESTED.
WE REVISED THE STATE'S WORKFORCE
PLANNING MODEL REVISED UPWARD
MOBILITY GUIDELINES WE'VE
CREATED NEW EMPLOYEE ONBOARDING
AN ORIENTATION INFORMATION.
WE'VE RECREATED CREATED THE
HUMAN RESOURCE CREDENTIALING
PROGRAM.
IN CONCLUSION MISTER CHAIRMAN
THE CSI PROCESS TO DATE HAS
INVOLVED NEARLY TWO HUNDRED
STATE EMPLOYEES EMPLOYEES
REPRESENTATIVES MOST OF THEM
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS. WHO'VE
CONTRIBUTED THROUGH FORTY
DIFFERENT WORK GROUPS AT
DIFFERENT TIMES THEY PUT FORWARD
THE RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE CSI
COUNCIL. FOR APPROVAL.
CSI TRAILER BILL FOR WHICH WE'RE
HERE TO TESTIFY TODAY WE ARE
PROPOSING VARIOUS TECHNICAL
CHANGES THAT WILL CONTINUE THE
IMPROVEMENT OF THE CIVIL SERVICE
IMPROVEMENT SYSTEM. AS I'VE RUN
THROUGH TODAY WITH ME TODAY IS
DAY REX AND THAT HE WILL WORK
WALKS THROUGH QUICKLY THE
SPECIFICS OF OUR CSI TRAILER
BILL THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF THE
NAVY'S MY NAME IS DAVE REX AND
I'M FROM THE GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AGENCY.
THIS TRAILER BILL MAKES
TECHNICAL CHANGES IN THREE AREAS
IT REMOVES BARRIERS FOR PERSONS
WITH DISABILITIES.
CLARIFIES THE ROLE BETWEEN THE
STATE PERSONNEL BOARD AND KELLY
PRACTICES.
TO HELP RECRUIT MORE PERSONS
WITH DISABILITIES INTO STATE
GOVERNMENT. WE WANT TO MODIFY
THE LIMITED EXAMINATION AN
APPOINTMENT PROCESS OR LEAD.
LEAP AS SECRETARY MENTIONED IS
AN ALTERNATIVE FORM OF TESTING
AVAILABLE TO PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES. IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN WE REMOVE THE
REQUIREMENT THAT LEAD CANDIDATES
HAD TO SERVE A PROBATIONARY
PERIOD.
PRIOR TO THIS CHANGE ELITE
CANDIDATE IN ESSENCE HAD THE
SERVE TWO PROBATIONARY PERIODS.
BECAUSE THEY WERE ALREADY
EVALUATED THROUGH THE JOB
EVALUATION.
OUR PROCESS.
THIS TRAILER BILL CLARIFIES IT
ONCE A LEAD CANDIDATE PASSES HIS
OR HER JOB EVALUATION.
THEY WILL BECOME PERMANENT
EMPLOYEES.
IT ALSO GIVES THE ABILITY FOR
CULTURE TO MERGE A LEAP REFERRAL
LISTS.
AT THAT NON LEAP HIRING LISTS.
THIS HELPS MITIGATE ANY
UNCONSCIOUS BIAS IN THE HIRING
PROCESS.
IN THIS IS ALSO CONSISTENT WITH
CURRENT REGULATION.
A SECOND AREA IS TO CLARIFY THE
RULES BETWEEN SUPER SNOWBOARD
AND KELLY CHAR.
THIS IS A LEFT OVER FROM THE TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN GOVERNOR'S
REORGANIZATION.
PLAN NUMBER ONE.
THE GOVERNOR'S REORGANIZATION
PLAN REORGANIZED STATE PERSONAL
BOARD IN COLLEGE ARE BY VESTING
IN COUCH ARE THE POWERS DUTIES
AND AUTHORITIES NECESSARY. TO
OPERATE THE CIVIL SERVICE SYSTEM
PURSUANT TO CIVIL SERVICE LAWS
AND BOARD RULES.
GIVEN THE NEW RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN STATE PERSONAL BOARD AND
CULTURE ARE A FEW STATUTES
REQUIRE TECHNICAL CLEANUP TO
REFLECT THE NESTON NECESSITY OF
COLLABORATION BETWEEN THE TWO
AGENCIES.
BUT LASTLY.
WE WANT TO REMOVE OUTDATED
PRACTICES CURRENTLY FOUND
STATUTES.
WE BELIEVE OUR CHANGES IMPROVE
THE EXAM PROCESS BY ALLOWING FOR
THE USE OF MORE CONTINUOUS
EXAMS.
AS THE SECRETARY MENTIONED
EARLIER WE WANT TO MAKE IT
EASIER FOR JOBSEEKERS TO TAKE
EXAMS.
CREATE LARGER CANDID POOLS INTO
REDUCE DEPARTMENTAL EXAM COSTS.
WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE IT EASIER
FOR MPLOYEES TO TRANSFER TO
DIFFERENT POSITIONS WITHIN THE
STATE.
THIS GIVES STAFF THE ABILITY TO
GAIN A BROADER.
SET OF SKILLS
AND CAN PENSION POTENTIALLY FIND
A BETTER JOB PERSON MATCH.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME I'D BE
HAPPY ANSWERING QUESTIONS
THANK YOU A FINANCE.
A TEAR IN THE PROPOSAL.
LL.
NEXT ROTOR WITH THE LA GO OVER
GENERALLY SUPPORTIVE WITH THE
MINISTRATIONS OF GOALS OF
IMPROVING THE CIVIL SERVICE AND
WE RAISED NO OBJECTIONS TO THESE
SPECIFIC TRAILER BILL. QUICK.
I'M EXCITED BUT WE PROGRAM LIKE
IT'S GOOD AND ENTIRELY AND LINK
QUESTLOVE HAVE HEARD A LOT OF
COMPLAINTS FROM.
PEOPLE OUT AGENCIES THAT THERE.
THE HIRING PROCESS IS QUITE
CUMBERSOME THERE'S REALLY NO
STANDARD MAY DRAG OUT. THE
OFFICIAL COME OUT PEOPLE TO HAVE
PATIENCE AND ALSO THE NEXT YOU
KNOW THE RETESTING AGAINST THOSE
WE KNOW STANDARD WITHIN A SET
NUMBER DAYS TO.
YOU KNOW CLOSING DATE AND TO
HAVE THAT YOU KNOW THE PROCESS
BEGINS SO CAN YOU COMMENT ON
THAT.
YOU'RE NOT WEARING IT JUST IN A
DIFFERENCE INCIDENTS THAT
SOULFLY LOAD AS JULIAN AFFECTING
JUST DRAGGING OUT I'VE HEARD. A
NUMBER REPORTS ON THAT.
WELL ON.
IT WEDNESDAY EXAMINATION HAS
BEEN TAKE HAS TAKEN PLACE AND
IT'S IT'S BEEN SCORED AND PEOPLE
CAN BE INTERVIEWED.
OFF THAT SCORING.
IT'S REALLY UP TO THE
DEPARTMENTS TO DO A VERY TIMELY
HIRING PROCESS BUT SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT I'VE MENTIONED A
MISTER CHAIRMAN TODAY. HAVE
IMPROVED ON THAT TIME FRAME IN
TERMS OF RECRUITMENT TO.
TESTING TO SCORING EXAMINATIONS
AND TO THEN THE HIRING PANEL AND
PROCESS IT THIS IS EVEN TESTING
SO MUCH AS TOUCHED ON THE ISSUE
CARE FOR MYSELF IT'S FOR
EXISTING EMPLOYEES THAT ARE.
PROMOTING TWO DIFFERENT CLASS SO
I SEARCH AND IT'S IT'S JUST IS
DRAGGING OUT BECAUSE THERE IS NO
STANDARD AND THAT'S THAT'S A
THING OF THE STATE BECAUSE YOU
HAVE DIFFERENT AGENCIES AND
THERE'S. REALLY DIFFERENT
STANDARDS IS THERE THOUGHT
ABOUT.
ABOUT FORMALIZING THAT.
THE IT'S PART OF OUR OVERALL
PACKAGE REDUCING THE NUMBER OF
CLASSES.
FOLKS.
EASIER OPPORTUNITY TO TRANSFER
WITHIN THE STATE.
REDUCES A NUMBER OF.
EXAM SO THEY CAN TAKE IT
CONTINUES EXAM WE HAVE TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONLINE
CONTINUES EXAMS CURRENTLY. SO.
RATHER THAN WAIT FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO GIVE AN EXAMPLE BE
EVERY TWO YEARS OR THEY'RE GONNA
BE STUCK.
WERE ENCOURAGING DEPARTMENTS TO
MOVE TOWARDS CONTINUES EXAM SO
BOOKS CONTESTS GET ON THE LIST
AND APPLY FOR VACANCIES.
SO IT'S ONE OF THAT ANSWER
QUESTIONS. OWE A LITTLE BIT BUT
BARRING CERTAIN.
CIRCUMSTANCES
FOR INSTANCE IF YOU PUT A JOB
ANNOUNCEMENT.
IS IT REQUIRED GOALS IN A
CERTAIN PERIOD OF NUMBER OF
TIMERS AT LEFT EACH AGENCY
DECIDE BUT THAT TIME PERIOD WILL
BE.
HOPEFULLY THEY DO A VERY TIMELY
BECAUSE THEY ARE THE HIRING
AGENCY AND THEY SHOULD WANT THAT
THAT UP POSITION FILLED AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE BUT THERE IS A TIME
FRAME GENERALLY SPEAKING.
RICHARD YOU WANT TO SPEAK TO
THIS.
RICHARD GO HAND CULTURE
DIRECTORS I I I JUST WANTED TO
JUMP IN WITH GOV SO I GETTING TO
THE QUESTION YOU ASKED THERE IS.
NOT ANY MEANT.
THERE'S NOT A SET TIME FOR HOW
LONG THE JOB CAN BE ADVERTISED
BUT THERE IS A MINIMUM AMOUNT OF
TIME THAT WE RECOMMEND. SO THAT
THE PEOPLE HAVE A CHANCE TO SEE
IT AND YOU KNOW IT'S PART OF A
MERIT SYSTEM. OUT RELATIVE TO
HOW LONG IT TAKES FROM THE TIMES
MY SUBMITS AN APPLICATION FOR A
JOB.
TOLD THEY DO INTERVIEWS THAT'S
REALLY A MATTER OF HOW HIGH
PRIORITY BITS FOR THE
DEPARTMENTS WE'VE ENCOURAGED
DEPARTMENTS THROUGH. OUR
RECRUITMENT EFFORTS AND OUR
ADMIN.
SORT OF WORKING GROUPS THAT WE
OVERSEE. TARA.
BE MORE EXPEDITIOUS IN THIS
BECAUSE WE LOSE TOO MANY
APPLICANTS THEY THEY WAIT TOO
LONG IT MAY TAKE A JOB WITH THE
CITY YEAR WITH THE COUNTY YEARS
OR SOMEWHERE ELSE BECAUSE WE
DON'T GO BACK ON TIMELY. AND
WE'RE ALSO ENCOURAGING
DEPARTMENTS TO BE BETTER ABOUT.
LETTING FOLKS KNOW WHERE THEY
ARE IN THE PROCESS OF THEIR NOT
AGAIN JUST HANGING OUT THERE AND
WHERE WERE AUTOMATING SOME OF
THAT IN. OUR ECO SAN ARE A
CALPERS WEBSITE. THAT.
WE HAVE TWO PHASES OF WERE
STILL BUILDING OUT ONE WE JUST
READ ONE OUT THAT'S THE.
APPLICATION WIZARD IT'S SORT OF
LIKE TURBOTAX FOR TRYING
APPLYING FOR A JOB WALKS YOU
THROUGH THE PROCESS.
WE'RE DOING A SECOND PIECE ON
THAT THAT.
DOES THE SAME THING FOR THE
EXAM PROCESS AND IN THE THIRD
PIECE WHICH WILL BE OUT BY
SUMMER IT GETS TO I THINK WHAT
MORE WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
AND IT'S A SUMMARY SCREEN IT
TELLS. A JOB APPLICANT WHERE
THEY ARE IN A PROCESS WHAT EXAM
LIST THERE ON. WHAT?
JOBS I'VE APPLIED FOR IN THE
STATUS OF THOSE THINGS SO WE WE
HOPE ALL OF THAT PROVIDES MORE
TIMELY INFORMATION TO PEOPLE
BOTH TRYING TO GET A STATE JOB
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN THOSE
TRYING TO MOVE WITHIN THE
SYSTEM.
SO.
A LOT EFFORTS ON THAT FRONT.
OKAY THANK YEAH IT'S DIFFERENT
HAVING WORKED FOR COUNTY.
INVOLVED THE HIRING PROCESS IN
THE CITY. AND THEN.
FOR THE STATE BEFORE I CAME HERE
SO.
I'VE GOT DISEASE LAW DIFFERENT
THINGS AND.
IT WOULD DO A GREAT JOB BUT I'M
THIS LOT MORE WORK TO DO SO THIS
PARABLE OF THE PUBLIC COMMENT.
EMOTIONS BECAUSE ITEM.
CHEMICALS PUBLIC COMMENT I DO
HAVE ANOTHER QUESTION UNDER THE
PROPOSED LIMITS GO FAR ENOUGH TO
ACHIEVE MEANINGFUL CIVIL SERVICE
CHANGES.
DO THESE THAT WHERE A RECKONING
IN THE TRAILER BILL CORRECT
THERE'S ALWAYS MORE WORK TO BE
DONE CIVIL SERVICE IMPROVEMENT I
SEE IS A LONGER TERM EFFORT.
AND THERE ARE OTHER POLICY AREAS
IT YES STILL NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED.
OKAY.
MISTER BUREAU IN QUESTIONS.
I DON'T THINK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND AND JUST
ONE MORE QUESTION OF WHAT THE
OVERALL GOAL FOR THE CIVIL
SERVICE CHANGES.
TO IMPROVE OUR SYSTEM TO TO JUST
AS YOU ASKED OF US AND MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE NEED TO RECRUIT
PEOPLE IN A MORE TIMELY WAY WE
NEED TO HAVE. A PROCESS THAT IS
NIMBLE THAT MORE IS MORE LIKE
WHAT THEY'RE USEDTO IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR OR OTHER PUBLIC
SECTOR. WE CRY ON HIRING FORUMS
WEEK WE HAVE TO BRING OURSELVES
AND OF THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY.
MOST OF OUR POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES TRULY DATE BACK INTO
THE SIXTIES AND SEVENTIES.
THERE IT JUST TO FOLLOW UP I
MEAN OBVIOUSLY SOME.
WHEN YOU SIMILAR APPLICATION OR
WHATEVER IT IS. MOST.
JOB UP PIECES OF CLOSING DATE
AND SUMMER OPEN ENDED INTO UNTIL
PHIL.
BUT IT WOULD BE ISSUES SEE. HOW
THESE DEPARTMENTS ARE DOING AND
I REALIZE SOME HAVE PARTIES AND
SOME DON'T BUT? I THINK REALLY
WANNA HOME ON THAT SOME
DEPARTMENTS ARE JUST.
YOU KNOW THE IN RETESTING JUST
BECAUSE ARE DRAGGING THEIR FEET
SO.
MAYBE HAVE SOME TYPE OF STANDARD
WERE STANDARDIZED THAT'S WITHIN
THE BIGGEST THING.
IT'S JUST IF IF IF WE DON'T.
.
ISSUE DIRECTIVES AGAIN LEAVE THE
UPTOWN DEVICES AND WE NOT
ACCOMPLISH THESE THINGS SO.
IF YOU COULD ADDRESS THAT
SOMEHOW THAT WE AGREE FULLY WITH
YOU I MEAN AS AS MISTER CALLAHAN
JUST SAID.
THE HIRING MANAGER SHOULD MAKE
HIRING A PERSON A PRIORITY SO
THEY CAN GET THE WORK OF THE
PEOPLE DONE QUICKLY AND WHERE A
HUNDRED PERCENT BEHIND THAT AT
ALL TIMES EVEN DONE SOME LEAN.
PROCESSES AND SOME OF OUR AGE
OUR SHOPS TO. AND CUT DOWN ON
THE NUMBER OF PROCESSES THAT THE
DEPARTMENTS GO THROUGH. TO HIRE
PEOPLE WE'VE DONE THAT AND
NUMEROUS OTHER DEPARTMENTS AND
IT'S HELPED A LOT.
GREAT THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
LITTLE THIS ITEM OPEN.
I THINK.
LET'S REMOVE ONTO ISSUE NUMBER
TWO.
BUT BROWN THAT OKAY ALSO
PLANNING AND RESEARCH SINCE
THOUGHT REACH
.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
THE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND STAFF I AM
DE THIS KENTUCKY FOR THE
DIRECTOR OF THE COMPLETE COUNT.
SUCH TWENTY TWENTY THIS'LL BE MY
THIRD DECENNIAL CENSUS IN THIS
ROLE.
AS YOU MAY BE AWARE IN THE TWO
THOUSAND UP EFFORT THE STATE
MADE A SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT
OUTREACH TO SUPPORT THIS FEDERAL
OPERATION.
THE LESSONS LEARNED ABOUT THAT
EFFECTIVE.
OUTREACH
HAS CARRIED THROUGH EVEN TWO
DECADES.
LATER.
WE REALLY ARE GOING TO BE
FOCUSED AROUND A COORDINATED
EFFORT CROSS SECTORIAL WHICH
WILL ENGAGE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
TRUSTED MESSENGERS.
PUTTING QUESTIONNAIRE ASSISTANCE
CENTERS IN THE RIGHT PLACES AT
THE RIGHT TIME STAFF WITH THE
RIGHT PEOPLE. AND DOING A MULTI
LINGUAL MIGRATORY GATED MULTI
MEDIA OUTREACH CAMPAIGN.
THIS PROPOSAL THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING AT WAS INITIALLY DRAFTED
FOLLOW LAST YEAR AND DID NOT
IMAGINE THE ADDITIONAL BARRIERS
WE ARE NOW FACING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. WHICH MAY IMPACT THE
ABILITY OF THE U. S. CENSUS
BUREAU TO COLLECT AND COMPLETE
AND ACCURATE COUNT ACROSS THE
NATION BUT MAINLY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
SO I AM HERE TODAY TO DISCUSS
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
REQUESTING FORTY POINT THREE
MILLION AND TWENTY TWO LIMITED
TERM POSITIONS TO STAFF THE
CALIFORNIA COMPLETE COUNT
EFFORT.
TO COMPLEMENT THE US CENSUS
BUREAU'S OUTREACH.
FOCUSSING ON HARD TO COUNT
POPULATIONS.
THIS PROPOSAL REQUEST THE
FUNDING TO BE APPROPRIATED IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND
AVAILABLE FOR THE DURATION OF
THE THREE YEAR EFFORT CROSSING
OVER FISCAL YEARS TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. TWENTY
NINETEEN.
TWENTY TWENTY AND TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
FINANCE THINK HERE BECKER KIRK
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE FORTY POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS INCLUDING THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET COMBINED WITH TEN MILLION
DOLLARS PROVIDED IN THE CURRENT
YEAR. REPRESENTS OUR BEST
ESTIMATE OF THE FUNDS NECESSARY
TO AID IN A COMPLETE CAO OF
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS.
WE DO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE
SOME UNCERTAINTY AS THE FUNDS
NECESSARY DEPEND ON U. S. CENSUS
BUREAU ACTIONS. THE OUTCOME OF
LITIGATION REGARDING THE
INCLUSION OF A CITIZENSHIP
QUESTION ON THE CENSUS
QUESTIONNAIRE. AND FUTURE COSTS
OF MEDIA ADVERTISING WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING
DISCUSSIONS WITH COMMITTEE STAFF
AND STAKEHOLDERS REGARDING THE
CENSUS EFFORT.
ELIOT.
CAROLYN SHE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE GIVEN THE
SUBSTANTIAL IMPACT OF OF THE
CENSUS ON THE COUNTY CALIFORNIA.
A ON A FEDERAL FUNDING RECEIVED
BY CALIFORNIA WE DO I BELIEVE
THAT.
ICE A STATE OUTREACH EFFORT IS
IN THE STATE'S FISCAL INTEREST.
BUT YOU.
AND THE RIVER A COUPLE QUESTIONS
I'M ONLY STAFF DO YOU HAVE IN
PLACE THIS TIME.
SO THAT WE COUNT UMPS IT'S
TWENTY TWENTY OF US OFFICE HAS
FILLED FOR POSITIONS OUT OF THE
SIX THAT WERE APPROVED FOR THIS
FISCAL YEAR. THEY INCLUDE MYSELF
THE DIRECTOR I HAVE MY DEPUTY
DIRECTOR MY SISTER DIRECTOR OF
MARKETING COMMUNICATIONS AND OUR
OFFICE MANAGER AND COMPLETE
COUNT COMMITTEE LIAISON THEY'RE
JUST SITTING THERE IN THE SECOND
ROW. ON THE TIMELINE TO HIRE THE
TWO ADDITIONAL POSITIONS WHICH
ARE THE ASSISTANT DIRECTOR OF
EXTERNAL MEDIA RELATIONS AND THE
ASSIST DIRECTOR OF OUTREACH
POSITION IS WITHIN SIXTY DAYS.
WE ARE AGGRESSIVELY RECRUITING
THESE POSITIONS IN OUR HAVE
CONDUCTED SOME INTERVIEWS AND
THE POSITIONS ARE CURRENTLY
ADVERTISE ON CALLIE CHARTER.
THEIR WEBSITE THE CAPITAL
MORNING REPORT AND ON OTHER
GOVERNMENTAL.
WEBSITES.
NO THAT'S FOR THIS YOU. KNOW.
HOW YOU GOING TO SET UP THE
PROPOSED CONTRACTS WITH A
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
GIVEN THE SMALL SIZE OF YOUR
TEAM?
SO WE HAVE IN THE PROPOSAL
MOVING FORWARD SIXTEEN
ADDITIONAL SPOTS A TOTAL OF
TWENTY TWO.
SO WE HAVE.
DECIDED TO DIVIDE UP OF A PIECE
OF THOSE THAT WILL FOLLOW UNDER
OUR DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR CONTRACT
MANAGEMENT.
IT IS VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE DO
CONTRACTS AND NOT GRANTS TO
ENSURE THE COUNT ABILITY A ALSO
UNDER OUR DIRECTOR OF OUTREACH
WILL HAVE REGIONAL. OUTREACH
MANAGERS WHO WON'T JUST BE DOING
OUTREACH BUT THEY'RE ACTUALLY
PROVIDING THAT SECOND LAYER OF
ACCOUNTABILITY BECAUSE I'LL HAVE
TO REVIEW ALL THE PLANS OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE COMMUNITIES
ORGANIZATIONS AND HOW THEY ARE
SPENDING IT DOWN ON THE GROUND.
IN YOUR MIND IS F. SUFFICIENT
STAFFING.
THE TWENTY TWO YES.
.
IN A TWO THOUSAND WE HAVE FIFTY
FIVE STAFF.
SO THAT I TAKE THAT AS A NO
THEN.
AND.
I THINK WITHIN THE ADDED
BARRIERS THAT WE'RE FACING.
I THINK FOR THE FORTY MILLION
WEEK ITSELF IF THE CASINO.
I SUIT WEEK WE ALL YOUR MONTHS
TORRANCE HERE YES REALIST
SUPPORT.
MORE STAFF BECAUSE IT IS A BIG
JOB THE MORE WE GO OUT INTO THE
COMMUNITY AND THE MORE WE'RE
HEARING ABOUT THE FEAR THAT'S
OUT THERE.
IT WAS GOOD THAT THE AROUND
THAT.
WHO'S GOING TO ADMINISTER AND
MONITOR THE PROPOSED CONTRACTS.
A COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
SO WE YOUR DIVIDING THE STATE
UP.
THE DEMOGRAPHICS RESEARCH UNIT
AT THE O. F. IS DIVIDED THE
STATE UP INTO ELEVEN REGIONS UM
IN TWO THOUSAND WE I'M NOT SURE
HOW MANY REASONS WE HAD THERE
BUT WE ALSO HAD WHAT WE CALLED
ADMINISTRATIVE CBO'S. WHICH ARE
BUSY NAY THE COULD BE
FOUNDATIONS WE USE THE LA URBAN
LEAGUE FOR EXAMPLE DOWN IN LOS
ANGELES IS A REALLY COMMUNITY
ENGINE NGOS COMING ORGANIZATIONS
THAT HAVE CAPACITY. TO REACH
INTO THE AUDIENCE.
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO REACH HER
TO COMPETITIONS BUT THEY WILL BE
DOING PRETTY MUCH THE
ADMINISTRATIVE TASK OF
MONITORING.
AND MAKING SURE THAT THE ANA
BOOTS ON THE GROUND ARE DOING
WHAT THEY'RE SAY THERE SAY
THEY'RE DOING.
PERHAPS IT WOULD JUST COUPLE OR
QUESTIONS COME HOW CAN WE ENSURE
THAT THE INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THE
CENSUS. IS IN PLACE BY NEXT
YEAR.
SO WE HAVE A PLAN OF FOR THE
SIXTEEN ADDITIONAL POSITIONS A
CONTINGENT THEIR APPOINTMENTS AS
A CONTINGENT UPON.
THE BUDGET APPROVAL A WE'LL BE
POSTING THOSE.
RIGHT AWAY IN TERMS OF WE HAVE
TO GO THROUGH THE CAL H. ARE
HIRING PROCESS.
SO.
AND RECRUITMENT I'M ALWAYS
LOOKING FOR LOOKING FOR GREAT
PEOPLE SO THE MORE YOU CAN TELL
PEOPLE TO COME ABOARD.
BUT HE ESCRIBIR OF THE
QUESTIONS.
NO QUESTIONS JUST JUST COMMENTS
I THINK THIS PARTICULAR CENSUS
CYCLE IS GOING TO BE MORE
DIFFICULT THAN IN PREVIOUS
YEARS.
AND I WANT TO CAUTION THAT BOND
PART OF WHAT HAPPENED IN IN IN
MY DISTRICT IS THAT. BECAUSE OF
THE NUMBER OF FAMILIES THAT
HAVE.
.
FOR LACK OF A BETTER WORD AND
MIXED IMMIGRATION STATUS.
THEY'VE BEEN TOLD NOT TO ANSWER
DOORS ENOUGH TO GIVE ANY
INFORMATION OUT AND.
TO BE VERY WARY OF ANYBODY
COMING ASKING FOR INFORMATION SO
WE'RE GOING TO REALLY HAVE A
VERY DIFFICULT TIME.
GETTING GOOD ANSWERS AND PART OF
THE CHALLENGE IN THE REGION AS
WELL IS THAT THERE ARE MULTIPLE
FAMILIES LIVING IN ONE BEDROOM
AND TWO BEDROOM APARTMENTS SO.
YOU MAY END UP.
GETTING ONE PERSON LIVES IN THE
APARTMENT BUT UNLESS THEY GIVE
YOU THE INFORMATION ON EVERYBODY
AND THAT A STUDY WAS JUST JOT
DOWN. RECENTLY I WAS JUST
RELEASED LAST WEEK ON FARM
WORKER HOUSING AND.
SHOWED THAT A LARGE PERCENTAGE
OF THE INDIVIDUALS LIVING IN IN.
ARE RESIDENCES ARE.
LIVING WITH ON.
.
THEY'RE NOT FAMILY MEMBERS AND
THAT IN THE IN OTHER WORDS
THEY'RE RENTING THE SPACE BUT
THEY'RE NOT BY BLOOD RELATED AND
SO.
WE HAVE A TREMENDOUS TASK AND
WE'RE GONNA HAVE A HARD TIME
GETTING INFORMATION UNLESS WE
CAN GET THE TRUST OF THE
COMMUNITY SO I WANT TO WORK WITH
YOU IT MAY MAKE SENSE TO.
INCLUDE THE LEGISLATURE IN
WHATEVER PLANS THAT YOU YOU
UTILIZE SO THAT WE CAN GET AS
MUCH DONE ELECTRONICALLY SO NO
ONE'S GOING OUT TO PEOPLE'S
HOUSES AND SO I WANT TO BE
HELPFUL IN THAT. IN THAT PROCESS
SO I KNOW THAT.
YOU'RE GONNA BE PUTTING ALL
THAT INTO THAT INTO THAT
FRAMEWORK THAT WE HAVE TO WORK
TO WORK FROM BUT. THE MORE THAT
WE GET THE MESSAGE OUT THAT WE
NEED THIS INFORMATION IT'S NOT
SO THAT PEOPLE CAN BE PICKED UP
AND DEPORTED BUT BE SO THAT THEY
CAN BE COUNTED. AND THAT THAT'S
THE WAY THAT WE GET RESOURCES
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
WE GOT TO MAKE THAT CLEAR.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE TODAY AND WILL BE IN YOUR
DISTRICT ON THE THIRTY FIRST
RIGHT IN MAINE SALINAS URBAN
ECONOMIST GABRIELLE'S COMMENTS
IN ITS TRUEST YOU TO STAND UP AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE. WANT TO BE
INVOLVED IN HELP WE TALKED ABOUT
AT LENGTH AMONG SOME MEMBERS IN
OUR CAUCUS A WITH STAFF WE
DISCUSSED YESTERDAY LINK. AND
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT UNDER
CAPITOL ONE ARE IMMIGRANTS
AFRAID. IT OBVIOUSLY IS
CALIFORNIA STANDS TO LOSE A LOT
OF FUNDING.
WE WILL MAKE SURE THAT DOES NOT
HAPPEN SO WE WANT TO AS MUCH AS
WE CAN. TO ASSURE FOLKS THAT WE
NEED THE INFORMATION.
OF THIS HELPS CALIFORNIA HELPS
US ALL.
SO THIS POINT ONE OF THE PUBLIC
COMMENT.
SO THOSE ARE TO SPEAK PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
IT'S OKAY TO SAY ME TOO. WE KNOW
WE NEED TO FUND THIS MORE AND.
WERE SUPPORTIVE OF IT SO REALLY
MAKE THIS HAPPEN SO.
WE'VE GOT A.
FAIRLY FEE AGENDA SO.
PLEASE BE BRIEF IN YOUR
COMMENTS.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JOSEPH BEGIN ATTRACT A POLICY
WHICH HAS LED THE COALITION FOR
HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS JEALOUS
PART OF THE CENSUS POLICY
ADVOCATES IN NETWORK A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORTS AMONG.
MULTIPLE ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS
THE SECTOR WE SUPPORTED THE
NOTION OF INK INCREASING FUNDING
FOR AT THE CENSUS AB ESPECIALLY
TO TO THOSE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
HAVE ARE HAVE TRUSTED I'M.
PICKING THE TRIALS OF IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE A FEEL PLAN FOR THEM IN
REGARDS TO THE ELECTRONIC.
MODEL THAT THE CENSUS IS MOVING
FORWARD LATER BECAUSE ARE GIVEN
A LOT OF COMMITTEES OF COLOR DO
NOT HAVE ACCESS TO TO THOSE
SERVICES TO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT. IN IN IN COMBINATION OF
THAT PLANNED TO TAKE TO TAKE
THAT IN CONSIDERATION IN
ADDITION TO THAT CHANNEL HAS
DIFFERENT OFFICES IN SUMMER
GUARDINO THE CENTRAL VALLEY IN
LA. AND SO WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S DIFFERENT PLAN
FROM DIFFERENT REGION GIVING
THEM ALL ALL ALL SCI FI ASSAULT
AND WOOD THAT WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST FOR MORE FUNDING IS
SPECIFICALLY FOR. OUR REGION
EDUCATION FIVE FOUR DOES ARE TO
RETALIATES OUR INDIVIDUALS THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AMBER'S MARTHA GROW REPRESENTING
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT OF THE
BUDGET ALLOCATION OF THE FORTY
POINT THREE MILLION. AND ALSO AN
ADDITIONAL EIGHT POINT SEVEN
MILLION SPECIFIC FOR LOS ANGELES
COUNTY WE ARE THE HARDEST TO
SURVEY COUNTY IN THE NATION.
NEARLY FORTY FIVE PERCENT OF THE
COUNTIES HOUSEHOLDS ARE IN HARD
TO SURVEY CENSUS TRACTS
WHICH MAKES THE COUNTY HIGHLY
VULNERABLE TO AN UNDERCOUNT. THE
CALCULATION AS WELL FOR THIS
FIGURE WAS MADE BEFORE THE
DEPARTMENT OF COMMERCE DECISION
TO INCLUDE A QUESTION ON
CITIZENSHIP ON THE CENSUS FORM
WE NEED TO ACCURATELY PUT THAT
INFORMATION DOWN IN ORDER FOR
THE SENSES TO BE COUNTED. THAT'S
WHY IT ISN'T IT HIM IMPERATIVE
THAT WE INCLUDE.
ALL THE THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
THE COUNTY'S GREATEST ASSETS IN
THE CENSUS EFFORT IS OUR
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE LIKELY
COUNTY LIBRARIES AND FACILITIES
AND THE ABILITY TO REACH OUR
EXISTING CLIENTS THAT IS ON
GETTING ACCESS TO OUR SERVICES.
AND THEY HAVE A RELATIONSHIP OUR
CLIENTS HAVE A RELATIONSHIP WITH
OUR.
COUNTY EMPLOYEES AND.
AND AND AND OUR IN OUR
FACILITIES THE CENSUS EFFORT IS
A PARTNERSHIP ALSO WITH OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS EIGHTY EIGHT
CITIES AND ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY
UNINCORPORATED AREAS. AND THE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
HAVE STRONG TIES WITH THEIR
RESPECTIVE COMMUNITIES.
THE COUNTY WOULD UTILIZE FUNDS
FROM THE LOCAL CCC'S ALLOCATION
TO SUPPORT THE LOCAL REGION WIDE
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH CAMPAIGN.
NOT ONLY DOES THE COUNTY WERE
COLLECTIVELY WITH THE CBO'S TO
ENSURE AND SUPPORT THEIR EFFORTS
AND WILL COMPETE COMMUNITIES BUT
WE ALSO FILL IN THE GAPS. FOR
OTHER GROUPS THAT DO NOT FALL
WITHIN THE REACH OVER CBO
PARTNERS. SUCH GROUPS INCLUDE
THE ELDERLY DISABLED RENTERS
INDIVIDUALS LIVING IN CROWDED
HOUSEHOLDS THAT JUST WHICH YOU
MENTIONED ASSEMBLY MEMBER COVER
YOUR. AND I'M INDIVIDUALS LIVING
IN RURAL AREAS LIKE ANTELOPE
VALLEY FOR EXAMPLE THE HOMELESS
THOSE IN THE HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM. THE MILITARY VETERANS
AND BUSINESSES AMONGST OTHERS
THE COUNTY RELIES ON THE CENSUS
DRIVE DICK SENT.
MIX A TO SIX IS THE BASIS OF
FOR FEDERAL FUNDING ALLOCATIONS
FOR PROGRAMS THAT SERVE
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS SUCH AS
MEDICAID. FOSTER CARE ASSISTANCE
TEMPORARY ASSISTANCE FOR NEEDY
FAMILIES AND SECTION EIGHT
HOUSING.
THEREFORE ADMIT ALSO ONE MORE
THING.
JUST REFERENCE WHAT BROUGH WHAT
THE REDUCTION LOOKS LIKE A
PROVIDED A COUPLE OF CHARTS ON
DEMONSTRATING THE SIGNIFICANT
CUT OF THE AXIS TWO SENSES.
INFORMATION BY THE FEDERAL.%
RESOURCES THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY
PROVIDED SO YOU CAN SEE THE
DIFFERENCE
SO THEREFORE WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING THAT WE ARE REQUESTING
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
I INGRAM ACLU OF CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT OF INCREASE
FUNDING FOR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO DO CENSUS
OUTREACH TO ENSURE THEY GET AN
ACCURATE COUNT AND CALIFORNIA
GETS ITS FULL SHARE. OF FEDERAL
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
CENTER CERAM SANTANA
REPRESENTING CHINESE FOR
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION WE ARE A
CIVIL RIGHTS COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION. AND SINCE OUR
FOUNDING IN NINETEEN SIXTY NINE
WE HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN EVERY
CENSUS FOR THE LAST FIVE
DECADES.
OUR COMMITMENT TO CENSUS IS
CONSTANT IT'S TO ENSURE A FAIR
AND ACCURATE COUNT FOR HARD TO
REACH COMMUNITIES.
I'M ALL OF THIS EXPERIENCE HAS
REALLY TAUGHT US MANY LESSONS
BUT THE KEY LESSON IS.
THAT CENSUS TWENTY TWENTY WILL
BE LOST OR ONE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL.
AND FOR US TO WIN WE BELIEVE
THERE ARE THREE CRUCIAL
COMPONENTS THAT NEED TO BE IN
PLACE.
FIRST
WELL WE'RE ASKING THE
LEGISLATURE TO INCREASE THE
FUNDING FOR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION OUTREACH.
THE RESEARCH SHOWS AND OUR
EXPERIENCE SHOWS THAT THE HARD
TO REACH COMMUNITIES ESPECIALLY
THE IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY. REALLY
SEE THE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AS TRUSTS HAVE
MEANT MESSENGERS AND WE WOULD
ASK FOR THEIR ROLE TO PAY OUT
FUNDED MORE.
SECONDS CALIFORNIA REALLY NEEDS
A LANGUAGE ACCESS PLAN FOR THIS
TO BE DONE RIGHT AND WE'RE
DELIGHTED AND HAPPY TO SEE THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS TO HAVE
SUCH A PLAN. BUT I WOULD ALSO
ASK THAT IN SUCH A PLAN FOR IT
TO BE MEANINGFUL AND ROBUST THAT
MIGHT SMALL LANGUAGE GROUPS ARE
INCLUDED.
NANA WRITTEN LANGUAGES ARE
AND ADDRESSING LANGUAGES FOR
GEOGRAPHICALLY CONCENTRATED
COMMUNITIES.
THERE'S ALSO A FEDERAL A A
NATIONAL ADVISORY GROUP FOR THE
CENSUS WHO HAS.
PROVIDED RECOMMENDATIONS
NOVEMBER TWENTY SIXTEEN.
ON LANGUAGE ACCESS AND THE HARD
TO REACH AND WE BELIEVE THAT
REPORT HAS MANY KEY ELEMENTS FOR
A CALIFORNIA STATE PLAN AND
THIRD. OF WE THINK IT'S REALLY
CRUCIAL THAT AND CBO
INFRASTRUCTURE TO ROLLOUT CENSUS
IS IN PLACE SOON. THE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT.
SERVICE THE HARD TO REACH NEED
TO BE ABLE TO RAMP UP BEFORE THE
NEXT FISCAL YEAR STARTS.
AND THEY NEED TO KNOW THAT THOSE
DOLLARS ARE COMING SO THEY CAN
PLAN EARLY SCALE UP HIRE AND
TRAIN THE APPROPRIATE STAFF
WHICH ARE ALL SENSES BEST
PRACTICES. WE THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME.
BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
ISSUE THREE WILL GO AHEAD IF YOU
HAVE COMMENTS ON THAT GOOD
INCLUDE THAT NOW.
FOR THE OTHER FOLKS
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN. US REMEMBER
ARTICLE YOU KNOW WHO THE
CHALLENGE OF IT WITH A NASA
PROJECT CALIFORNIA I'M
REPRESENTING. THE SENSES POLICY
ADVOCACY NETWORK HERE TODAY. A
WE'RE NETWORK OF STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATIONS WORKING TOWARDS A
FAIR AND ACCURATE CENSUS AND
TWENTY TWENTY. UP REPRESENTING
MANY HARD TO COUNT ON
COMMUNITIES.
FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO THANK
THIS COMMITTEE FOR AN
AUGMENTATION OF FUNDING FOR
RECESSES.
BUDGET IN THE LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET.
I AM AND I ALSO WANNA I'M SURE A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF GRATITUDE
TO THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE FOR
INCLUDING A FORTY POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL. INDUCED
YEAR'S BUDGET.
THIS LEADERSHIP IS NEEDED.
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA HAS A LOT TO
LOSE IN THE POLITICAL CLIMATE ON
THE FEDERAL LEVEL. CALIFORNIANS
INTENSELY BEING UNDERMINED IN
ATTACK AND SENSES TWENTY TWENTY
IS AB ONE AVENUE IN WHICH IT'S
BEING DONE SO. WE ARE PLEASED TO
SEE THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL HIGH
OR HOWEVER WE BELIEVE IT'S NOT
ENOUGH FUNDING THE STATE SHOULD
AND NEED TO INVEST A LOT MORE
THAN FORTY POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS PROPOSED.
I THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE FOR A
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
THE NETWORK DID AN ANALYSIS OF
JUST HOW MUCH IT WOULD COST CBO
TO DO OUTREACH USING VARIOUS
METHODS THAT HAVE BEEN USED IN
THE PAST AND WILL BE USED AND
CENSUS TWENTY TWENTY.
AND FOR INSTANCE ARE AT DISNEY'S
EXAMPLE JUST LOOKING AT THE
LATINO POPULATION ARE NUMBERS
EXCEEDED THE TWELVE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ALLOCATED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. WE BELIEVE
IT'S GONNA ON COST AROUND TWENTY
ONE MILLION DOLLARS TO REACH
HARD TO COUNT.
OF POPULATIONS TRACTS OF
ELECTING A COMMUNITY.
AND WE HAVE ABOUT EIGHT TO NINE
DIFFERENT HTC POPULATIONS.
THIS IS NOT EVEN OUR INCLUDING
THE COMPLICATIONS OF THE
CITIZENSHIP QUESTION.
HAVING SAID THAT WE'RE NOT
PROPOSING A HARD BUDGET ASK
TODAY BECAUSE WE DIDN'T WE WANT
TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH YOU AND
THE LEADERSHIP AND
ADMINISTRATION. AND
ADMINISTRATION IN LANDING A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH AND
AMOUNT OF FOR THIS EFFORT.
AND WE WANT TO PROVIDE ANALYSIS
FOR YOU TO DO THAT.
IT IS FAR FAR TOO IMPORTANT TO
COUNT FOR CALIFORNIA TO
UNDERMINE THE BUDGET FOR CENSUS.
UNDERWRITING CENSUS FUNDING WILL
MEAN UNDERMINING CALIFORNIA
SOMETHING WE CANNOT AFFORD TO DO
YOU.
IT IS NOT JUST WHAT WE WANT IT
IS WHAT IS NECESSARY THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND WITH
THE QUIRK TO WORKING WITH YOU.
LET ME SAY THIS
ITS BUDGET STUFF APPEARS WORK ON
THIS.
.
FOR A LONG TIME WE'RE GOING THE
SPEAKER'S OFFICE AND BUDGET
CHAIR. TING.
FORTY MILLION AS A STARTING
POINT IS FAR INSUFFICIENT TO
FUND THIS.
SO SO CASEY ME TO WELL
AGREEMENT.
THE LONG HEARING SO BREVITY
WOULD BE MUCH APPRECIATED
PLEASE.
AND EVEN IF IT IS AN ACTIVE AS
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA ALSO PART OF
ITS IS POLICY OUTFIT I WORK. ON
SOME OF THE PART OF ADDITIONAL
CONDITION
THANK YOU.
PERFECT YOU NEED.
YOU NEED A DISEASE OF THE
COUNCIL ON AMERICAN ISLAMIC
RELATIONS CALIFORNIA THE
NATION'S LARGEST MOST OF THE
RIGHTS GROUP ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THAT YOU.
HAS A FEW NANOMETERS NOTHING I
WITH CHILDREN NOW ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE ITEM BECAUSE OUR
CHILDREN.
WHO LIVING IN FAMILIES AND FOR
THE ITEM THAT MISATO VITAL SPOKE
UP?
RELEASED FROM SUPPORT
BUT YOU.
JERRY GOT MORE NOW ARE WITH
PEOPLE CALIFORNIA THE LARGEST
ARE GRASSROOTS FAITH BASED
ORGANIZING NETWORK IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA ALSO MEMBER OF THE
CENSUS POLICY ADVOCACY NETWORK.
ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
JOHN MICHAEL EQUALITY CALIFORNIA
WHERE ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
CENSUS POLICY ADVOCACY NETWORK
AND LGBTQ FOLKS ARE MEMBERS OF
MANY OTHER COMMUNITIES AND
THAT'S WHY IT'S TREMENDOUSLY
IMPORTANT TO US TO MAKE SURE
LGBTQ FOLKS ARE COUNTED THANK
YOU BUT YOU.
AFTER A MISTER CHAIR JENNIFER
FEARING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFITS ON BEHALF OF OUR MORE
THAN TEN THOUSAND MEMBERS WE
OUGHT STAND LINE.
WITH THOSE FROM THE POLICY
NETWORK OF EXPRESSED DESIRE FOR
CONTINUED AT CONVERSATIONS AND
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE HOURS FUNDING
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON NO I BOTTOM OF
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION WE SERVE
LOW INCOME RURAL FARM WORKER
COMMUNITIES. THROUGHOUT THE
STATE WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT OF
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE CAN
YOU BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO
PROVIDE MEANINGFUL OUTREACH AND
EDUCATION. SECONDLY WHERE IN
SUPPORT OF OPRF IMPLANTING
RESEARCH TRAVEL LANGUAGE ACCESS
PLAN BY APRIL TWENTY NINETEEN WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
STAFF AND. A ALL THOSE INVOLVED
AT THE CENSUS IN THE LEGISLATURE
GOING FORWARD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
CHRISTOPHER GALLIANO FROM THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER.
IT WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF OUR
MORE FUNDING TO COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL AS I
INTENTIONALLY OUT THE CHALLENGES
IN ADDRESSING I LANGUAGE ACCESS
ARM AS IT RELATES TO THIS. ASK
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON HAVE LAIN A
SCHOOL WHETHER WITH CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION HERE ON
BEHALF OF ELIAN SINK.
ACROSS SECTOR COLLABORATIVE AND
NOW LAY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
BUDGET AUGMENTATION IN THE
PRIORITIZATION OF HARD TO COUNT
COMMUNITIES AND ALSO HERE TO
EXTEND TO LEGISLATURE THAT IN
TWENTY TEN. IT WAS A PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN PHILANTHROPY AND OUR
STATE LEADERS THAT REALLY HELP
MAKE A DIFFERENCE AND. WE HEARD
A STAND READY AND EXTEND OUR
INTERESTS BEING PARTNERS AND
THAT'S.
THANK YOU.
UNDER HER WITH MALTA MEXICAN
AMERICAN LEGAL DEFENSE AND
EDUCATIONAL FUND ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
WITH AN EMPHASIS ON DEVELOPNG
A LANGUAGE ACCESS PLAN THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ALEJO ANOTHER
BAND REPRESENTING NEXT AND
CALIFORNIANS DRUNK SUPPORT. THAT
YOU.
THE RECRIMINATIONS ALL THIS ITEM
OPEN WE HOLD IT OPEN.
AND IF AND
.
SO WE KIND OF COVERED ITEM
THREE.
THAT RICH LANGUAGE ACCESS.
SO I'VE OF TO FROM THE FOLKS
THAT TESTIFIED EARLIER PUBLIC
COMMENT I.
TOLD THE GOOD INCLUDE THAT.
DID YOU.
I JUST TO AND MY APOLOGIES ITS
ONE OF THOSE AFTERNOONS BUT. I I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S ALREADY BEEN
SOME DISCUSSION ON WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PLAN IS TO
DEVELOP A LANGUAGE ACCESS
PROGRAM.
OF I CAN I CAN TALK FURTHER
ABOUT IF YOU ACTUALLY IF YOU
WANT MY JUST A QUICK SUMMARY
ABSOLUTELY SURE.
THE LANGUAGE ACCESS COORDINATOR
POSITION HAS BEEN IDENTIFIED AND
WE WILL BE WILL BE HIRED TO
ASSIST WITH LANGUAGE.
SUPPORT SO POSITION WILL ALSO BE
MONITORING.
AND AUDITING AND THE LANGUAGE
ACTS ACCORDING TO PARTICIPATE ON
THE LANGUAGE TEACHER VISION AS I
WAS ACCESS IS CRITICAL AND
IMPORTANT OF THIS CAMPAIGN SO AS
PART OF THE GROUND STRATEGY THE
SCOOBIES ORGANIZATIONS.
WILL HAVE CONTRACT REQUIREMENTS
ADDRESSING THEIR LANGUAGE AND
CULTURAL COMPETENCIES THAT WILL
BE DEPLOYED AT THE GROUND LEVEL
SO. WE'LL HAVE ONE PERSON TO DO
THAT'S ALSO WORK ON THE REPORT
FOR IS A ITEM THREE. BUT ALSO
WITH IN OUR.
RESTORE OUTREACH MANAGERS THEY
ALL WILL HAVE THAT HOT AS WELL
SO IT LIKE AN OFFICIAL
COORDINATOR AND THEN ACROSS ALL
CONTRACTING. WITH COMMITTEES
ORGANIZATIONS ON AND ALSO WITH
THE COUNTIES. WILL BE A LANGUAGE
ACCESS
OPPONENTS OF WHICH THEY NEED TO.
LOAD UP IN THEIR PLAN BEFORE
THEY DO. ANY STATE DOLLARS AND
OUR EYES ARE ARE YOU GOING TO BE
PUTTING OUT A MORE DETAILED PLAN
ON US CAN WE EXPECT TO. HAVE
MORE INFORMATION THAT THE PUBLIC
WILL BE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING ON.
PLEASE YES
OKAY HAVE THE EARTHY WEED OUT
REACHING CREATION STRATEGY IS ON
THE FIRST DRAFT IS WHEN WE
COMPLETE CONVENIENCE. WILL BE.
DUE OCTOBER FIRST GREATNESS
INCOMPLETE COUNT WELL IT GOES
WITHOUT SAYING THAT THAT IVAN.
SIGNIFICANT INTEREST IN THIS
SITE GIVEN THE DIVERSITY OF OUR
STATE WHEN IT COMES TO.
LANGUAGE ACCESS AND I THINK
ANYTHING THAT WE CAN DO TO
ENCOURAGE AS FULLY FLESHED OUT
AND AS COMPREHENSIVE A PLAN AS
POSSIBLE WE WOULD APPRECIATE.
AND THEN THE SECOND QUESTION.
IS AROUND CENSUS OUTREACH.
OBVIOUSLY WE APPRECIATE WHAT
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS INITIALLY
PROPOSED FOR CENSUS BUT I THINK
THERE IS.
CERTAINLY SENSURROUND STATE
THAT WE NEED TO DEVELOP MORE
FUNDING TO CENSUS OUT REACH
PARTICULARLY GIVEN WHAT THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION HAS
SUGGESTED MY GUESS IS YOU'VE
TALKED ABOUT THIS A BIT BUT. OUT
WHAT SORT OF PLAN AT THIS POINT
YOU HAVE AROUND CENSUS OUT
REACH.
WELL WELCOME TO THE BUDGET.
DOING BOTH AN AIR GAME AND A
ON GAME IN THE GROUND RAIN OF
COURSE IS THE ADMINISTRATIVE OF
AND THE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. THE AIR GAME IS
REALLY TO PROVIDE THAT SURROUND
SOUND IT'S CHANGED A LOT IN
TERMS OF MEDIA ADVERTISING SINCE
TWO THOUSAND TEN ALONE.
USING SOCIAL MEDIA AND USING A
LOT OFTHE OTHER DIGITAL
ADVERTISING THEIR MORE MIKE
RETARDED BUT WE ALSO HAVE SCHOOL
OUTREACH THAT WE'RE DOING
BECAUSE OF COURSE YOU KNOW THAT.
STUDENTS CAN BE PARTICULARLY IN
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENT
HOUSEHOLDS CAN BE REALLY KEY
MESSENGERS AND THAT SOMETIMES
THEY ACTUALLY END UP FILLING OUT
THOSE FORMS.
ALSO HAVE CASEWORKER OUTREACH
WHICH IN TWO THOUSAND AND TWO
THOUSAND TEN WE WORK WITH THE
WOMEN INFANTS AND CHILDREN'S
PROGRAMS SCOTT OF JUST GIVE YOU
AN EXAMPLE OF WORKING WITH
LOCALITIES IN IDENTIFYING. A
CASE WORKER SPECIFIC.
BECAUSE THESE PEOPLE SERVE
THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
HARDEST ACCOUNT AND THEY HAVE
TIME WITH THEM
AND IN PARTICULAR THE WOMEN
INFANTS AND CHILDREN PROGRAM
THEY HAVE. YOU KNOW TEN TO
TWENTY MINUTES EACH MONTH WHERE
THEY MEET WITH THESE YOUNG
MOTHERS AND EDUCATE THEM ABOUT
NUTRITION BUT WE CAN ALSO WE'VE
USED IN THE PAST DECENNIAL
CENSUS TO WHERE THEY CAN EDUCATE
THEM ABOUT.
HOW TO FILL OUT THE FORM AND
WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT?
WE ALSO HAVE A COUPLE OTHER
COMPONENTS SECTOR OUTREACH AND.
OUR STATE AGENCY WORKING GROUP
WHICH WE DIDN'T BOTH TWO
THOUSAND AND TWO THOUSAND TEN
BECAUSE MANY OF OUR STATE
AGENCIES THE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE A D. M. V..
SOME OF THE SOCIAL SERVICES
THEY ARE RIGHT THERE ON THE
GROUND LEVEL IN TERMS OF SERVICE
PROVISION THEY MAY NOT BE
EXACTLY THE MOST TRUSTED
MESSENGERS AND MAYBE THINK THAT
COMMUNITIES ORGANIZATIONS ARE.
BUT THEY CAN ALSO PROVIDE THAT
SURROUND SOUND ABOUT WHY IT'S SO
IMPORTANT AND WHY SERVICES CAN
BE IMPACTED IF THEY'RE NOT
COUNTY.
I'LL JUST MAKE THE COMMENT THAT.
AGAIN WHY PRE SHEET WHAT IS
FROM PROPOSED THUS FAR I THINK
WE HAVE A WAYS TO GO BEFORE I AM
GOING TO FEEL COMFORTABLE THAT
WE HAVE ENOUGH MONEY INVESTED.
TO ADEQUATELY ENSURE THAT WE'RE
COUNTING EVERYBODY.
PARTICULAR WHEN IT COMES TO TO
SUCH AS OUR REGION AND I'M ALSO
THE PERSPECTIVE THAT IT IS.
FOLKS ON THE GROUND WHO CAN HELP
US AS A STATE DO THE BEST JOB OF
COUNTING EVERYONE SO.
TO THE CHAIR INTO OUR COLLEAGUE
SO YOU KNOW I CERTAINLY HOPE IN
THE COMING. WEEKS WE'LL BE ABLE
TO HAVE MORE OF A CONVERSATION
OF WHAT THAT ADEQUATE AMOUNT IS
I KNOW THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
DISCUSSION AMONG DIVERSE
STAKEHOLDERS OUTSIDE THIS
BUILDING BUT ALSO. BETWEEN
ADMINISTRATION AND OUR.
ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE ON
THE CENSUS THE SUBCOMMITTEE AND
OTHERS AND I HOPE THAT IN THE
NEXT COUPLE OF WEEKS WE CAN ALL
GET ON THE SAME PAGE WITH THAT
LOOKS LIKE.
SELECT.
GREAT THANKS KNOWING FULL
EMPLOYMENT WHICH IS COMMON THE
TOUGH PART IS. YOU HAVE HALF THE
STAFF YOU HAD IN THE LAST
CENSUS.
AND WHO CLIMATE TODAY IN
WASHINGTON FOLKS BEING. I MEAN
GENERALLY SCARED. TO REPORT.
THAT THAT THAT THAT'S A FOUR
STRINGPARTS THE STATE BECAUSE
AGENCIES THAT NEED.
AND SHOULD ASK FOR MONEY.
AUGMENTATIONS DON'T BECAUSE
THEY'RE TOLD BY THE BOSSES.
TWO THOUSAND AND THE STATE.
AND THAT IS B. S..
THAT IS BE F. HAVING HALF THE
STAFF THEY HAVE YOUR HURLEY WAS
CHU BUT THEY HAVE TWENTY TWO
STAFF. AND PRIOR THAT FIFTY
FIVE.
I'M THAT IDEA I'M GLAD YOU
MENTIONED IT I'LL REITERATE THE
BEST PART OF WHAT YOU JUST SAID
THANK YOU HIGH MID BROTHER.
ENOUGH THAT THE FRUSTRATING
BECAUSE WE'RE TOUGH TIME THIS IS
MONEY CALIFORNIA.
THAT IF WE DON'T GET THE CORRECT
SINCE HIS WE LOSE WE ALL LOSE SO
IT'S LIKE I I'M ALL FOR GIVEN.
IT MAKES THIS IS YOU NEED TO GET
A ADEQUATE CAL.
THAT'S WE JUST THE FRUSTRATING
PART WITH WITH.
.
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
THAT IS FRUSTRATING.
FIND AT IF WE IF WE CAN GET THE
BEST COUNT WE CAN THAT'S.
I I JUST LEAVE IT AT THAT NON
OBVIOUSLY WE DON'T HAVE A FORMER
HERE SO WE CAN VOTE ON THIS I
THINK THERE'S A RISK RESPONSE
FROM OUR LEFT. YET.
YOU.
BROADLY SPEAKING IN REGARDS THE
CENSUS ITEM JUST WANTED TO
MENTION THAT THE FUNDING AND THE
POSITION COUNT IT'S INCLUDED IN
THIS REQUEST. COMBINED WITH FEES
CONTRACTED.
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION
RESOURCES THAT WOULD BE USED
THEY DO REPRESENT OUR BEST
ESTIMATE. WE DO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THERE IS SOME UNCERTAINTY GIVEN
THIS EFFORT. WE DO OF COURSE
ACKNOWLEDGE THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE CENSUS TO CALIFORNIA AND ITS
BROADER IMPACTS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS WITH COMMITTEE
STAFF AND STAKEHOLDERS REGARDING
THE CENSUS THANK YOU I THINK.
MAYBE MAYBE ONE THEY'LL JUST SAY
AN ADDITIONAL AT THE CHAIR JUST
SAID I THINK WE ALL APPRECIATE
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE CENSUS AND
I DO THINK THE FIRST AMOUNT THAT
WAS SUGGESTED IN THE AND THE JEW
IN THE JANUARY BUDGET. WAS A
GOOD STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
BUT WE'RE IN A DIFFERENT WORLD
RIGHT NOW NONE OF US EXPECTED
THAT THAT. CITIZENSHIP QUESTION
WOULD ACTUALLY BECOME PART OF
THIS. AND WHETHER THE RIGHT
ANSWER TO HOW WHAT WE SPEND ON
THE BUDGET IS.
DOUBLE WHAT WE HAVE FOUR FIVE
TIMES WHAT WE HAVE I THINK WE
NEED TO BE THINKING IN TERMS OF
A ORDER OF MAGNITUDE. UP BECAUSE
IF WE GET THIS WRONG I THINK WE
ALL KNOW THE CONSEQUENCES OF
WHAT THAT'S GOING TO MEAN FOR US
FOR. A DECADE IF NOT MORE SO.
I WILL CERTAINLY BE OPEN TO
SUPPORTING A MUCH SIGNIFICANT
AUGMENTATION ANDERSON AND
CERTAINLY TO THE BUDGET STAFF
AND AND LEADERSHIP AS WE THINK
ABOUT IT I VERY MUCH HOPE THAT
WE PUT UP A MUCH BIGGER NUMBER.
WITH A REAL PORTION OF THAT
GOING TO REACH.
BUT YOU.
SOMEONE ISSUE NUMBER FOUR.
PRECISION MEDICINE.
GOOD AFTERNOON SCOTT MORGAN WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE PLAYING IN
RESEARCH.
SITTING IN FOR DOCTOR ELIZABETH
BAKA.
DOES LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
PRODUCES MEDICINE.
PRECISION MEDICINE INITIATIVE
WAS LAUNCHED BY THE GOVERNOR IN
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN.
SUPPORT FROM THE LEGISLATURE IN
A THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN STATE
FUNDING.
THE PROGRAM HAS GROWN INTO
TWENTY THREE MILLION STATE AND
IF YOU AND THIS NEW OF THE ONLY
INITIATIVE OF ITS KIND. AT THE
STATE LEVEL THERE IS A FEDERAL
INITIATIVE THAT WERE ALSO
WORKING WITH.
.
THIS IS A REPRESENTS UNIQUE
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE STATE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA SYSTEM
PRIVATE NONPROFIT AND ECONOMIC
INDUSTRIES.
THE AND INDUSTRY.
PIECES MEDICINE AIMS TO USE
ADVANCED COMPUTING TOOLS TO
INTEGRATE AND ANALYZE THE VAST
AMOUNT OF MOLECULAR CLINICAL
ENVIRONMENTAL AN EPIDEMIC
EPIDEMIOLOGICAL SEE THAT WERE
TEN TIMES FAST
DATA WORLDWIDE KNOWN TO DEVELOP
NEW DIAGNOSTICS THERAPEUTICS
AND.
MECHANIC MECHANISTIC INSIGHTS
INTO DISEASE BOTH RARE UNCOMMON.
AND UNDERSTAND WHY INDIVIDUALS
RESPOND DIFFERENTLY TO A
DIFFERENT DISEASES AND DIFFERENT
TYPES OF THERAPIES.
.
PART OF THAT THE.
CURRENT ISSUE TO INCLUDE ASSIST
ECKSTINE EVER PRECISION MANAGE.
MEDICINE ADVISORY COMMITTEE THAT
WAS CREATE IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN. AND WHICH WILL BE
COMING OUT WITH A REPORT A LATER
THIS YEAR.
.
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL ALLOW
CALIFORNIA TO CONTINUE TO
BELIEVE TO BE A LEADER IN THIS
AREA.
THE BUDGET TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE DOES.
PROPOSED TO TRANSITION THESE
EXISTING PRECISION MEDICINE
INITIATIVE TO A STANDALONE
NONPROFIT INSTITUTE THE
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE TO ADVANCE
PRECISION HEALTH AND MEDICINES.
A SOME QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN
RAISED ABOUT THE NEED TO CHANGE
THE PROGRAM.
FROM.
STATEMENT INITIATIVE TO A A
NONPROFIT.
INSTITUTE. NOW WE BELIEVE THAT
THE NONPROFIT.
IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT CAN
CREATE A.
A BECAUSE THE CREATION OF THE
INSTITUTE ALLOWS.
FOR.
OF AND MORE.
STREAMLINED AND UP TO BETTER
OPPORTUNITIES FOR DONATIONS OF
FUNDS FROM A PRIVATE ENTITIES IN
INDUSTRY AND FUNDERS. AYE IN
KIND SUPPORT ANOTHER REVENUE.
THAT MAYBE AND I'M A AVAILABLE
AYE IT FROM THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
IT ALSO ALLOWS FOR MORE
COLLABORATIVE I'M.
.
SPACE IF YOU WILL.
ACROSS BLUNDERS UNIVERSITIES
AND MEDICINE MEDICAL RESEARCH
INSTITUTES.
.
OUT OF THE INITIAL THIRTY
MILLION THAT.
IS PROPOSED EXPECT FIFTEEN
MILLION TO GO OUT FOR PROJECTS
DURING THE FIRST YEAR.
TRAILER BILL ALSO INCLUDES.
A LANGUAGE FOR SIXTEEN MEMBERA
BOARD OF DIRECTORS AND WE'VE
WE'VE HEARD SOME SOME. SOME
FEEDBACK ON THAT IS IF THAT
MAYBE IT'S A PRETTY LARGE BOARD
OF DIRECTORS SO WE ARE OPEN TO
YOU.
REDUCTIONS IN THAT NUMBER NOW
AND WORKING WITH AND
STAKEHOLDERS AND CONSTITUENTS ON
THAT AS WELL.
.
IN CLOSING CALIFORNIANS ROLE TO
DANCE PRECISION MEDICINE SERVES
AS A MODEL TO OTHER STATES
AS WELL AS ENABLES THE
PARTNERSHIPS NEED ACROSS SECTORS
IN AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL.
THIS WORK IS IMPORTANT SO THAT
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO BE A
LEADER IN TECHNOLOGICAL WHO
TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATION. HEALTH
PROMOTION AND HEALTH CARE.
THE STATE'S ADDITIONAL OF
INVESTMENT HAS SPURRED UNIQUE
COLLABORATIONS BETWEEN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AYE DAMIEN
NONPROFIT AND PRIVATE SECTORS.
IN TUNING TO SUPPORT EMERGENCY
FIELD OF PRECISION MEDICINE
THROUGH THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE TO ADVANCE
PRECISION HEALTH AND MEDICINE
WILL BE VITAL TO MAKING
IMPORTANT VANCE'S TO. IMPROVE
BASED ON MY LIMITED EXPERIENCE
IN THE MEDICAL.
FINANCE.
RECORD DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
BUT.
ESTABLISHING THE CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTE TO ADVANCE PRECISION
HEALTH AND MEDICINE WILL REALLY
HELP TO INTEGRATE SUCCESSFUL
COME FINDINGS FROM THE EXISTING
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS AND
PRECISION MEDICINE INTO THE
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM.
THE INSTITUTE WILL REALLY MOVED
BEYOND THE DEMONSTRATION
PROJECTS THAT WE FUNDED TODATE.
AND WORK TOWARDS TRANSLATING
THEM AND BRING THEM INTO HEALTH
CARE DELIVERY.
SPECIFICALLY FACILITATING PARA
REIMBURSEMENT OF PROVEN
ADVANCES.
INCORPORATING SUCCESSFUL
OUTCOMES INTO THE HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM.
COORDINATING THE SHARING OF DATA
SETS AND ADVANCED TRANSLATIONAL
RESEARCH AND FACILITATING
FURTHER PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS AROUND PRECISION
MEDICINE THANK YOU SERGEANTS CAN
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS PLEASE.
THANK YOU DOYLE.
THE QUESTION OF MISTER TO.
I JUST SEVEN A SUPPORTER OF FIRE
INVESTING IN PRECISION MEDICINE
I THINK GET UP.
NOT ONLY IS IMPORTANT FOR ITS
OWN SAKE AND CERTAINLY THE
FUTURE MEDICINE BUT FOR
CALIFORNIA TO LEAD IN THIS AREA.
IS IMPORT TO AUSTIN OUR ECONOMY
SO.
SO I'M VERY OPEN TO SUPPORTING
THIS AND
AND AND.
AND WHAT THE GOVERNOR IS
PROPOSING TO HOPEFULLY MAKE SURE
THAT WE ALL. GET TO LIVE LONGER.
COMING UP IN THE PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU WISH TO SPEAK ON THIS ITEM.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BOB NAYLOR.
REPRESENTING STANFORD
UNIVERSITY WE'VE BEEN A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF THE PAST PROPOSALS.
THEY HAVE DEVELOPED A PEER
REVIEWED COMPETITIVE GRANT
PROGRAMS AND IT APPEARS THAT
WILL CONTINUE. AND WE THINK THIS
EXPANSION IS APPROPRIATE AND THE
PRIVATE. NONPROFIT WILL.
ATTRACT OF PRIVATE CONTRIBUTIONS
TO SUPPLEMENT STATE FUNDS THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS ALL OF IRAQ GRAY
CALIFORNIA LIKE SCIENCES
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT I
THIS IS EXACTLY THE TYPE OF
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP THAT
ADVANCES MEDICINE. AS WE KNOW
ADVANCES IN MEDICAL SCIENCE COME
A LONG WAY WE'RE GETTING MORE
AND MORE PRECISE ABOUT THE WAY
WE DELIVER THOSE.
TREATMENT SO GREAT EXPENSE
AGGRESSIVE FORTIN PROCEDURE
SPORT THANK YOU.
THIS ITEM UP GOING CLOSE PUBLIC
COMMENT SADDAM WAS ADDED TO FILL
TWO ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT BY THE
COMMITTEE. WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
WE HAVE A PLAN TO ADDRESS
LANGUAGE ACCESS BARRIERS.
PARDON.
ALL ALONG THAT IT LOOKS LIKE.
HE'S GOING TO NEED FOR THE
PROPOSED TRAILER BILL IN WHICH.
IS THAT RELATED TO THE TO THE.
TO THE CREATION OF THE
INSTITUTE.
YES YES SIR OUR FEELING IS THAT
THAT CURRENTLY.
MORE SOMEWHAT LIMITED IN IN OUR
ABILITY TO ACCEPT FUNDS.
TO ACCEPT IN KIND CONTRIBUTIONS.
BASED ON ON THE STATE IN IN THE
IN THE WAY WE OPERATE IN THAT
THE CREATION OF A NONPROFIT BOY
INCREASINGLY IT WILL GREATLY
EXPAND THAT ABILITY.
IN ALLOW WAS SPACE FOR A
VARIETY OF FUNDERS.
PRIVATE PUBLIC OTHERS TO TO
DONATE AND AND BE PART OF THE
PROCESS AND ALLOW FOR MORE
CLEVER ABOUT ATMOSPHERE WITHIN
THAT SPACE.
THANK YOU.
REPETITIONS ALSO LOCUSTS WILL
OPEN.
AND WE'RE GONNA PAUSE RIGHT NOW
THE SELFISH QUORUM.
COOPER HERE GROW.
CABALLERO CHIU. CHOI BY
THERE.
OKAY THE FIRST VOTE ONLY ITEMS
WILL BE ON ITEMS ONE THROUGH
SIXTEEN.
WE HAVE DOCTOR I KNOW THAT
DOCTOR TORREY IS LOCKED IN ALSO.
THE FIRST MOBILE ITEMS ONE
THROUGH SIXTEEN FIFTEEN THROUGH
TWENTY. TWENTY TO. TWENTY FOUR
TO THIRTY THIRTY TWO THIRTY
THREE AND THIRTY THRIVE THIRTY
FIVE TO FORTY TWO.
IS THERE A MOTION SO WITH.
SECOND.
A LITTLE HELP WITH.
COOPER.
I.
BRO.
CABALLERO.
CHIU. CHOI.
SECOND WHAT WILL BE ITEMS TWENTY
ONE OF THIRTY ONE THEIR MOTION
MOTION.
SECOND. LOCAL POLICE COOPER I.
THROW.
CABALLERO CHIU AYE CHOI.
OKAY BULLY ITEM SEVENTEEN LEVEL
SHIBLEY'S.
ROLL CALL.
S. MOTION THINK IT.
COOPER AYE BRO.
CABALLERO.
CHIU.
CHOI.
WILL I AM TWENTY THREE THE MOST.
SOCIAL SCIENCE.
TOTAL COOPER COOPER I.
BRO.
CABALLERO CHIU. CHOI.
WELL ITEMS ONLY THIRTY FOUR
PROMOTION.
SOME OF SAY.
COOPER I.
BRO.
CABALLERO.
CHU LAI CHOI.
YEAH NEXT WILL ISSUE NUMBER
THREE.
IS OUR MOTION.
AS FOR THE SENSES ARE RICH
LANGUAGE ACCESS. ALSO GONNA.
ROLL CALL.
COOPER I GROW.
COMING EURO.
CHIU CHOI AYE.
AND WE WE HAVE ONE MORE.
THAT BE A.
IS THERE TO HAVE A DEATH
SENTENCE OURSELVES.
ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN A STATEWIDE
HUMAN RESOURCES WORKLOAD.
WE GOT OF EMOTIONS THEIR SECOND.
SECOND SECOND ROLL CALL PLEASE
COOPER AYE BRO.
CABALLERO CHIU. CHOI.
BUT
WHICH TAKES US TO ITEM NUMBER
FIVE.
FIST CAO
PLEASED WITH THE RELEASE ARE
QUORUM SO.
BRIEF IS GOOD.
PREFIX GOOD
I GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS MARY IN BARCELONA INCH NEEDLE
AND I AM THE DIRECTOR FISCALE.
AND WITH ME I HAVE ONE OF OUR
PARTNERS.
THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE.
JENNIFER URBAN.
KATHY LEE OUT.
I JUST WANTED TO PRESENTE IN A
QUICK OVERVIEW OF WHERE WHAT THE
STATUS OF THE FISCAL PROJECT IS.
AND THE DISCOUNT HOT.
SYSTEM ENCOMPASSES ACCOUNTING
BUDGETING CASH MANAGEMENT
PROCUREMENT IN BANKING.
I AND TO KEEP IMPLEMENTATION WE
ARE BASICALLY HAVING. A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY FOUR DEPARTMENTS
CHANGE THE WAY THAT THEY DO
BUSINESS.
AND ELIMINATE SOMETHING CLOSE TO
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED LEGACY
EITHER MAINFRAMES OR
SPREADSHEETS OR OR THE WAY THAT
DEPARTMENTS HAVE BEEN DOING
ACCOUNTING PRIOR TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF A CENTRALIZED
SYSTEM.
WHEN IT IS COMPLETED A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY.
MORE THAN A HUNDRED FIFTY STATE
ENTITIES AND TWENTY THOUSAND
STATE EMPLOYEES WILL BE
UTILIZING THE FISCAL SYSTEM.
WHICH MEANS THAT THE BUSINESS
FOR THE SIXTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD WILL FINALLY BE AND
WINE AND TO AND SYSTEM.
SO CURRENTLY THIS SYSTEM HAS
BEEN.
DEPLOYED TO EIGHTY EIGHT
DEPARTMENTS THAT UTILIZE IT FOR
ACCOUNTING.
WE HAVE SINCE JULY TWENTY
SIXTEEN. VIZQUEL IS THE SYSTEM
FOR A COUNTY DEPARTMENT
ACCOUNTING PROCUREMENT AND
BUDGET FUNCTIONALITY.
THE PAST THREE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGETS HAVE BEEN PRODUCED
UTILIZING AND THE INFORMATION
THAT HAS BEEN. DONE INST
IMPORTED INTO FISTS CAO.
INCLUDING STARTING IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAS BEEN ABLE TO PRODUCE
THE ENACTED BUDGET AND PROVIDE
THAT TO THE LEGISLATURE TO THE
PEOPLE WITH THE SAME LEVEL OF
DETAIL. THAT BE INTRODUCED
BUDGET IS SO AGAIN THE MOST.
RELEVANT AND AND CRITICAL
BUDGETING DOCUMENT NOW IS AT THE
ACTUALLY ENACTED LEVEL. SO THOSE
ARE SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO IMPLEMENT.
SO FAR WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OFFICE GAO.
THE REMAINING FUNCTION SO IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE WILL BE
BRINGING ON IN JULY ANOTHER
APPROXIMATELY SIXTY FOUR
DEPARTMENTS.
AND WE ADOPTED V. S. P. R.
NUMBER SEVEN WHICH OUTLINES THE
STEPS IN TIMELINE FOR THE FINAL
PHASE OF THE IMPLEMENTATION. IT
WAS REALLY A MECHANISM TO TO
TRUE UP SOME OF THE DECISIONS
THAT ARE STEERING COMMITTEE HAD
MADE THROUGH THE COURSE OF THE
YEAR.
A GUEST BR DID NOT REQUEST.
YOU KNOW I'M AN EXPANSION OF THE
SCOPE. AND IT DOES.
.
INSERT TEAR OR CHANGE THE.
EXCUSE ME THE THE APPROACH THAT
WE'RE IMPLEMENTING FOR THE FINAL
PIECE WHICH IS THE CONTROLLERS
BOOK OF RECORD.
SO S. B. R. SEVEN SETS
MILESTONES TO INTEGRATE THE SCO
ONE LAST YEAR FUNCTIONALITY INTO
THE SYSTEM BY JULY TWENTY
NINETEEN. AND THEN IT'LL BE A
PERIOD WHERE THEY CAN.
PHASE OFTEN VALIDATE
SO THAT THE CASH NUMBERS IN THE
SYSTEM OUGHT CAN BE MORE EASILY
RECOGNIZE HAVE RECONCILED.
THE.
A.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH SHOULD I
KNOW YOU WANT ME TO BE BRIEF THE
SCO FUNCTIONALITY WILL GO LIVE
IN THE FIRST QUARTER. SO BETWEEN
JULY AND OCTOBER TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THAT THAT WILL INCLUDE DEPOSIT
SLIP FUNCTIONALITY ELECTRONIC
DEPOSIT FORMS.
YES YOUR REMITTANCE ADVICE
ONGOING PAYMENT RECORDS AND
VIZQUEL. AND INTEGRATION WITH
DEMAND BANKS.
AND THE LEYVA ZERO.
BALLOTS ACCOUNT INTERFACE WILL
ALL BE PART OF THAT THE
TREASURIES FUNCTION SO REALLY WE
WILL CONTINUE TO IMPLEMENT THE
S. T. O. THE SCO'S GO LIVE.
THROUGH A SERIES OF FIVE
MILESTONES THAT WE OUTLINED IN
THE US PR.
THERE ARE BLUFF HUNDRED AND.
PERHAPS I LOST MY NUMBER A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX.
SHE A HUNDRED AND FOUR SPRINTS.
TO BE DONE IN THESE FIVE
MILESTONES AND WE ARE CURRENTLY
IN ON SPRINT.
IN THE SPRINT PERIOD TEN OF
TWENTY NINE SO WE ARE MAKING
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS.
BY CHANGING THE WAY IN THE
METHODOLOGY IN THE APPROACH THAT
WE ARE UTILIZING TO ON BOARD.
THEN THE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE
WE EXPECT THAT WE WILL HAVE A
REDUCED RISK
TO BOTH.
.
AND TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AS THEY DO THE BOOK OF RECORD
AND SO.
THIS WAS AN IMPORTANT AND
PRUDENT DECISION TO CHANGE THE
IMPLEMENTATION TO ALLOW FOR A
MORE PHASED APPROACH.
BUT YOU.
FINANCE.
NEITHER ARE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE PURE SUPPORTER OF THE
AUGMENTATION OF THIS PATROL WAS
BUDGET TO BE ABLE TO
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENT THE.
TRANSITION FROM A LEGACY SYSTEM
TO THE FISCAL BOOK OF RECORD.
BUT WE ARE ALSO SUPPORTER OF
THE.
PROVISION LANGUAGE INCLUDED IN
THE BUDGET.
LL THERE THAT'S MY LIST AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
PREVIOUSLY PROVIDED COMMENTS ON
THIS ISSUE AT A PREVIOUS HEARING
OF THIS COMMITTEE THOSE COMMENTS
STILL STAND THERE ARE ALSO
OUTLINED WELL IN THE AGENDA. A
VERY BRIEFLY OUR PURSE ARE A
PRINCIPAL CONCERN IS THAT NOT
ALL ASPECTS OF THE PROJECT TO BE
COMPLETED WITHIN THE SCOPE OF
THE CURRENT FDR. OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS IN TO PROVIDE
THE LEGISLATURE OVERSIGHT AS ALL
THOSE ASPECTS ARE COMPLETED
PRINCIPALLY THE TRANSITION OF
THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE
UNDER THE SYSTEM AND ALL
REMAINING DEPARTMENTS.
KIM.
HE COULDN'T MEMBERS.
IN PUBLIC COMING THIS ITEM.
CAL CLOSE PUBLIC COMPLEMENT THIS
IS AN ACTION ITEM IS OUR MOTION.
TO PROVE BUDGET.
I THINK IT A.
WE HAVE LOCAL POLICE.
COOPER I BROKE.
CABALLERO CHIU CHOI.
COULD YOU THINK VIGOROUS
CHAIRMAN. LET'S MOVE ON TO OUR
LAST ITEMS THAT YOU NUMBER SIX.
PARTNER TECHNOLOGY DEPARTMENT
OVERVIEW OF BUDGET PROPOSALS
.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR GIVING US AN
OPPORTUNITY.
REPRESENTING THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY AMY TOWN DIRECTOR IN
THE STATE'S CHIEF INFORMATION
OFFICER. AND JOINING ME IN IS
OUR CHIEF ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER
MILES FOR NET.
TWO PERCENT ARE OUT BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL.
SO I'M GONNA TRY IT OVER TWO
MILES TO TO PROVIDE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HAS
AIMS THEM MY NAME'S MILES
BURNETT CHIEF ADMINISTRATIVE
OFFICER FOR. CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY.
LITTLE BIT SOMEONE SHOUTING INTO
IT.
THIS PROPOSAL REQUESTS FIVE
POSITIONS IN A BUDGET
AUGMENTATION OF FOUR POINT SEVEN
MILLION IN FISCAL YEAR EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN AND ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION ON GOING THERE AFTER
FROM THE TECHNOLOGY SERVICES
REVOLVING FUND.
TO PROVIDE CRUCIAL SUPPORT FOR
THE SECURITY OPERATIONS CENTER.
THE STATE WIDE DATA CENTER.
IN ADDITION TO THE FIVE
POSITIONS THE REQUESTED BUDGET
AUTHORITY WILL BE USED TO
ACQUIRE IT SECURITY EQUIPMENT
THAT WILL ENHANCE CD THESE.
VOTER.
VULNERABILITY SCANNING THE FOR
STRUCTURE.
A GREAT SECURITY ANALYTICS TOOLS
AND IMPROVE THE DEPARTMENT'S
NETWORK INTRUSION DETECTION
CAPABILITIES.
ONCE MOBILIZED THESE INTEGRAL
COMPONENTS WILL REINFORCE CDP'S
ABILITY TO COMBAT.
THE COMBAT THE GROWING NUMBER OF
IT CYBERSECURITY THREATS ON A
STATEWIDE BASIS.
THE FIVE NEW POSITIONS WILL
REPLACE EXTERNAL CONTRACTOR
SUPPORTING CD TEASE US SECURITY
OPERATIONS CENTER.
THESE CONTRACTS ARE SET TO
EXPIRE JUNE THIRTIETH TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN.
EXPENDITURES ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS PROPOSAL WILL WOULD BE HER
WILL BE DISTRIBUTED THROUGHOUT
CDP'S IT SERVICES.
AND WE ARE HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE THANK YOU
FINANCE.
SUPPORT PROPOSAL AS BUDGETED
ELLIOTT.
YOU QUESTIONS IN THE COMMITTEE.
ANYONE A PUBLIC PERSON SPEAK ON
THIS ITEM.
GIVE ME EXAMPLE OF HOW THE
RECENT CHANGES TO IT PROCUREMENT
FROM THE PROJECT OVERSIGHT AND
RESULTED IMPROVE DELIVERY OF THE
PROJECT.
YES I'D DUTCHER CAPRIVI.
I COULD NOT BE HAPPY TO ADDRESS
THAT AS WELL AS THOSE PREPARED
TO PROSELYTE AN OVERVIEW OF THE
ADDITIONAL SERVICES DIED THE
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY PROVIDE
WHICH INCLUDES. THE BUDGET
DELIVERY.
WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO GO
STRAIGHT FOR THAT FIRST ORDERED.
.
AND THEN ANTI THAT TO THE
CONTEXT WITH
SUBJECT TO THIS CHANGE PROPOSAL.
A WOULD YOU OR WOULD YOU LIKE US
TO TALK SPECIFIC ABOUT THE
CHANGE PROPOSAL AND THEN COME
BACK TO THE OVERVIEW BIGGEST
APPROACHES PROPOSAL I THINK
WE'VE ALL READ THE THE GENDERS
WERE.
REP SPEEDS THAT DEGREE IF YOU
CAN ASSESS THE QUESTION. OKAY
ALRIGHT.
SO SPECIFICALLY TO GOD I
AGAINST THE CHANGE PROPOSAL
SPECIFIC ABOUT THE THE
INFORMATION SECURITY PROGRAM BUT
YOUR QUESTION IS ABOUT THE IT
PROJECT DELIVERY YET SIDE OF
THINGS. CORRECT SO. DEEP BY
DEPRIVED TO DELIVERY OF THE
DEPARTMENT.
IF IT'S MORE ABOUT ON HOW DO WE
TIE THE PROJECT DELIVERY REVIEW
AS WELL AS DR A PREVIEW ES WELL
AS DOING THE OVERSIGHT REVIEW
WILD APPROACHES CONDUCTING. AND
WE DO WILL CONSULT THE SECURITY
OFFICE.
TO SAY HOW IS THE SECURITY
MEASURE BEING PUT IN IN THOSE
PROJECT DELIVERY SO BACK
COORDINATION WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT IS HAPPENING. I WOULD
REALLY WANTED TOINCREASE THE
MEASURE MEN ABOUT WHAT SECURITY
IT'S A FOREFRONT THINKING RATHER
THAN AND AT THE END. AND THAT'S
WHY HAVING A US SUPPORT ON
INFORMATION SECURITY PROGRAM TO
BOAST THE OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE PROJECT
AND DELIVERY SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE VERY INTERESTED IN. GREAT
THANK YOUS THE NEXT ITEM IS
THERE A MOTION.
A SECOND THAT. WE HAVE LOCAL
POLICE.
COOPER I GROW.
COMING ERA CHIU CHOI.
OKAY SO WE'RE GONNA. ASSUMING WE
DOLLAR.
IT'S MORE VOSSLOH HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN.
IT WILL HOLD YOU HEARING OPEN.
THANK YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU.
WHAT?
I WOULD.
SELECT.
OR.
YEAH WE.
NEXT YEAR IN THE BUDGET ACTORS.
REMIND ME NCARB GOING TO HAPPEN.
TO THINK THAT.
BUT THERE ARE.
OKAY I WAS.
PRETTY FAST.
THROUGH THROUGH
SO SO WE WERE.
I WILL HERE.
I.
OKAY SO IF YOU FOR THE VOTE ON
THE MISS COMING ERA.
MICHAEL.
FOR THE LITTLE ENCOUNTER.
OKAY.
AND THEN THE NEXT ONE IS.
ISSUE DO THREE SENSES ARE EACH
SUPPORT APART LANGUAGE.
ISSUE FIVE VISCO CHO EURO.
CHIU.
I IN ISSUE SIX THE I. T..
SECURITY POSITIONS.
OKAY.
KEEP.
OH AND THEN I'M SORRY ISSUE
SEVEN THE HUMAN RESOURCES
WORKLOAD.
PERFECT THANK YOU GUYS. REBEL
THEM